pop
[Musique]
m
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas bien pourquoi c'est pas bien tu
aimais pas j'arrive à toucher la [ __ ] de
débouler
[Musique]
je
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission avec nous ce soir le
distributeur du film de mel gibson
il n'a pas le film miss bourgogne en
régionale
les stars de la télé réalité se tape sur
la gueule
la vainqueure de la littérature
après paris brûle-t-il new york
brûle-t-il la bimbo de malibu revient à
nexter ciena tch 6 ans dans un couvent
pis l'homme de juillet
maintenant faisons beaucoup retour en
force
[Applaudissements]
le blind test de sydney et
à mon avis
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir j'avais oublié bonsoir
à c
[Applaudissements]
dans la scène où là c'est bien au début
après ça devient lourd un laurent lors
la statue est là et ben oui elle est
toujours à vendre elle fait aujourd'hui
7 kg et on est à 5000 euros
voilà mais ça peut monter un bien moi je
veux dire un mot de soutien pour le
chanteur ben aziz dont la cassette vient
d'être interdite et saisies en algérie
pour protester rendez vous le 6 avril à
20h30 à la maroquinerie 23 rue boyer
paris 20ème
[Musique]
non vous laissez moi tu voulais dire
quelque chose j'ai prévu un petit jeu
parce que des fois on s'emmerde ça
arrive donc j'ai prévu un petit jeu
quand il le souhaitera quand on a envie
de jouer tu tirera au sort un papier si
que des accents way simplement pendant
une minute fera que tout le monde à
cette table à cette table parle avec cet
accent voilà on verra bien si c'est pas
drôle dans le coup pour un montage la
gentille 1% à vue mais bon c'est l'
accent japonais mais je pense que
c'était un très bon jeu thierry tu vois
c'est tout de suite plus drôle c'est
formidable c'est très drôle non il faut
que tu dis c'est très drôle avec
l'accent japonais c'est très drôle
[Musique]
et maintenant la parler du film dont
tout le monde parle mais si tarak ben
ammar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
terriblement bonsoir on se gare sur
plateau de tout le monde en parle vous
avez 54 ans vous êtes un homme puissant
dans le cinéma et la télévision mais
jusqu'ici dans l'ombre et d'un seul coup
vous êtes sous les feux de l'actualité
puisque vous distribuer en france le
film de mel gibson la passion du christ
alors avoir d'abord un petit peu qui
vous êtes vous êtes né en 1949 en
tunisie père avocat puis ambassadeur
mère corse émigré en algérie est
convertie à l'islam quand elle a épousé
votre père est musulman
vous êtes héritier de la dynastie des
ben ammar longtemps associé aux
destinées de l'état tunisien votre tante
est l épouse du président bourguiba
vous avez bien connu hassan ii vous êtes
bien connu et yasser arafat et saddam
hussein et vous vous raconter comme ça
quand on vous y pousse un petit peu les
dîners de saddam hussein chez bourguiba
et c'est vrai que saddam hussein ne
venait avec ses gardes du corps avec
bourguiba voulait pas cliqué met les
pieds dans le palais présidentiel
pas seulement avec son cuisinier de peur
qu on empoisonne à il avait aussi le
cuisinier et donc bourguiba a dit il
mourra de faim où ils mangent manoury
tour où ils mangent pas et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est la musicienne à manger
la nourriture de absolument qui est
ribbon d'ailleurs alors en fait c'était
un passionné de cinéma
votre première production c'était le
messie de rossellini ensuite il ya eu
jésus de nazareth de zeffirelli la vie
de brian des monty python 13h45 avant
jésus-christ jean yanne la bible 21
épisodes pour la télévision et vous avez
failli produire le film de mel gibson
que vous distribuez aujourd'hui alors
pourquoi cet intérêt pour jésus
n'oublions pas qu'entre les différents
films de jésus j'ai fait les aventuriers
de l'arche perdue
ouais pirates de polanski et femme
fatale de monsieur de palma ouais jésus
revient régulièrement ma vie d'abord
parce que la tunisie est un pays qui
ressemble ou ressembler à l'époque à la
terre de jésus et donc les metteurs en
scène chercher les paysages qui pouvait
se prêter à jérusalem et à la galilée
ouais et puis ensuite il ya eu le succès
de jésus de nazareth le messie est comme
ça d'autres metteurs en scène ont suivi
ouais alors donc un homme de cinéma
aussi hommes de médias de télévision
puisque vous êtes un proche de
berlusconi de murdoch de leo kirch du
prince al-walid de patrick le lay de
vincent bolloré
vous êtes comme ça pendant que des
libéraux que des libéraux
vous êtes à un homme d'affaires
peut-être un affairiste dans le milieu
de la télévision non écoutez moi je suis
un homme du sud
ouais qui a essayé de réussir dans le
nord ouest à dire ici en france grâce à
ma mère je suis devenu également citoyen
français
donc je suis un franco-tunisien fier de
l'être
fier de mes origines et fier d'être
français il a fallu apprend très vite
que pour faire des films il fallait
trouver de l'argent
ouais fallait trouver de l'argent chez
qui chez les hommes d'affaires qui ont
des médias des télévisions eh ben c'est
comme ça que j'ai connus mur dob
berlusconi patrick de l'est pour
financer mes films ouais avec un homme
riche veuf fortune est estimée à 100
millions de dollars professionnels oui
oui ça y est mais société ouais parce
que également je vous rappellerai que
nous employons dans notre groupe
audiovisuel en france à peu près la
totalité d'industrie du son et des
effets spéciaux immortel en qui ben
hilal a été fait dans une de mes
sociétés et
alors
je crois que le disait parle de lui même
tara quand on met ça nous organiser pour
l'heure c'est pourri mais on est à vingt
dix mille euros c'est mieux on est déjà
25 minutes
il a dit ça me gave reffle a pris 10 am
il paraît que vous dites combien 10010
milan au sud sur mâle dominant
pour l'abbé pierre merci
bien alors aujourd'hui donc
effectivement c'est un tunisien musulman
qui n'est pas distributeurs de films à
l'origine qui distribue un film sur le
christ extrêmement controversée pourquoi
personne n'a voulu distribuer les films
à part vous tarak ben ammar
pour vous dire la vérité il ya trois ans
je devais produire le film mel gibson
était donc venu en tunisie en 2001 ou de
millas et puis après il ya eu septembre
2001 et tous les pays arabes tunisie
comprise même celle qui est une terre de
douceur et de toutes les religions
étaient interdits aux assurances pour
les metteurs en scène et les producteurs
du niveau de mel gibson
il est allé faire son fils en italie
quelques années plus tard je les
appelais et il me dit tu vis encore dans
ce pays d'intolérance et moi je croyais
qu'il parlait de mon pays d'origine
je ne comprends pas oublier non la
france et ça c'est pas un pli
d'intolérance c'est un grand pays de
tolérance médiers ben la plupart des
distributeurs pas tout ce qu'on rectifie
6,7 distributeurs clé avait décidé au
mois novembre d'année dernière que un
film sous titré sur jésus dont on avait
déjà créé une polémique sans avoir vu le
film
un de vos confrères aurait dit qu'il a
été jugé par contumace 1 et jenny mail
mais c'est pas vrai ce qu'on dit je les
appelais en février il est pas
antisémite on film m'a dit tu me connais
je suis un chrétien croyant je crois
dans toutes les races ça serait un péché
d'être antisémite ou raciste mehdi je
sortirai pas en france je lui ai dit eh
ben je le sors ben mhenni métier pas
distributeurs ginon mais je veux le
devenir
c'est comme ça que vous avez créés à ce
moment là qu'un tas distribution donc
société destiné au départ aux films de
mel gibson alors c'est un film qui est
extrêmement controversée 1 il est mis en
cause effectivement vous l'avez dit par
les organisations juives par l'église
catholique par les cinéphiles par les
adversaires de la violence à l'écran
alors avant d'en parler on va regarder à
quoi ça ressemble on va regarder la
bande annonce et je vais vous demander
targue en a marre de regarder votre
caméra en dix ans magnéto serge magnéto
observe
[Musique]
qui vaut le coup
vous
on a la passion du christ de mel gibson
avec jean
mika bellucci maya morgensztern
distribuer en france par tarak ben ammar
qui est notre invité ce soir pour en
parler avec nous j'accueille elie
chouraqui
[Musique]
et joachim au soir on sera quand j'ai
demandé de venir quand vous êtes
intéressé par l'histoire sainte la
preuve vous avez fait les dix
commandements
vous avez fait un livre avec andré
chouraqui dont on a parlé la dernière
fois que vous étiez ici et vous êtes
sensible à l'antisémitisme puisque vous
venez de réaliser pour envoyé spécial
un documentaire voilà alors le premier
point de la polémique sur la passion du
christ et l'antisémitisme donc et même
avant sa sortie aux usa le film a été
mis en cause par la licra local
l'anti-defamation league du rabbin
foxman et le producteur de miramax
harvey weinstein a appelé ses associés
français tfm pour leur demander de ne
pas distribuer le film dans notre pays
alors ya un certain nombre d'exemples je
pense qu'il faut être pratique je pense
qu'on va les prendre les uns après les
autres et voir si c'est des points qui
démontrent ray ou qui démontre
l'antisémitisme du film alors par
exemple ponce pilate sympa c'est là que
ponce pilate
c'est vrai que dans le film il donne
l'impression finalement de laisser les
juifs crucifié jésus est lui en fait il
n'a pas tellement envie de le faire sa
femme
encore moins que lui et c'est vrai que
c'est une version un petit peu
différente de ce qu'on a l'habitude de
lire ou de ou d'entendre ça non ponce
pilate est exactement comme tous les
autres films que j'ai faits sur jésus
ambigu hommes politiques calculateur
opportuniste et à la fin et décide pour
des raisons politiques
même s'il n'avait pas très envie de le
tuer c'est encore pire
un uma rien fait il a l'air gentil
flageller e et crucifié le moment loin
de moi l'idée de censure de condamner un
film c'est la responsabilité d'un auteur
quand il fait un film c'est sa vision
des choses et on peut la respecter ce
qu'on peut faire en suisse et porter un
jugement - j'ai vu le film c'est vrai
que c'est un film sectaire violent
raciste antisémite je le pense
profondément
je pense par exemple que l'empereur
excuser parce que sinon ça prenons
pilates pour commencer ponce pilate dans
le film est un humaniste et son humanité
sa réflexion sur la mort de jésus
fait peser tout le poids de la
condamnation à la crucifixion sur le
peuple juif et les rabbins qui sont là à
hurler pour demander la crucifixion
ça c'est pour ce pilote et une deuxième
chose moi que j'ai trouvé dans le film
très antisémites ou anti judaïque dix
ans c'est quand les grands prêtres paye
judas pour avoir trahi le christ qui lui
jettent les 32 ni à la figure il jette
une bourse et la bourse tombe par terre
ce qui n'est pas dans les évangiles et
est ce qu'on a le sud a semé a ramassé
par terre comme ça alors vous trouvez
pas que c'est un cliché un peu
antisémite ça pas du tout vous savez là
attendez dont jésus de nazareth il y
avait la même chose il n'a pas été
traité d'être antisémite
et puis je voudrais revenir il ya 2000
ans cinq ou six rabbins avait décidé de
condamner un autre à main jésus est un
rabbin il a grandi dans la grandeur de
la religion juive
il a eu un désaccord à l'époque et 2000
ans avec des gens qui étaient plus
conservateur que lui je ne vois pas en
quoi le peuple juif de l'image en mai je
suis d'accord n'est pas que cette image
de judas qui ramassent leurs parterres
comme ça c'est un gros cliché antisémite
quand même non mais c'est du cinéma
ouais c'est l'oeuvre d'un metteur en
scène il n'a qu'à pas la syrie a fait un
film on a droit dans la droite de porter
un jugement mais naturellement elie
chouraqui indique tout le monde les
droits de passer en jugement
il ya déjà plus de cinq cent mille
français qui ont vu le film
laissons les juger oui les us et
d'ailleurs il ya eu un sondage aux états
unis pardonnez-moi 60 millions de
personnes ont vu le film va se jouer
il ya eu un sondage organisé par le
congrès juif mondial pouvoir si on était
plus antisémite
avant ou après avoir vu le film mais ce
qu'on les plus ou moins à la grande
surprise on l'est moins et vous savez
pourquoi pas s'ils ont découvert que
jésus était un rabbin et qu'il était
juif et que la plupart des chrétiens ne
le savent pas et je suis sûr que parmi
les jeunes en france ça serait la même
chose
cette scène de judas qui ramasse les
deniers encore une fois il
et on peut avoir mille vision de ce film
une vision objective objectif traquer
vous êtes un homme trop intelligent je
pense pour manquer à ce point
d'objectivité que vous défendiez un film
que vous distribuez et pour lequel vous
avez de l'estiment permettez ans indique
elle vous avez de l'estivé je comprends
parfaitement
c'est vrai que dans ce film à différents
moments - j'ai eu les chaussettes mot
glissé le nom des mollets c'est quand
j'ai vu jude a essayé de ramasser
l'argent quand j'ai vu les rabbins lancé
des pierres quand j'ai vu ponce pilate
humanise je me suis dit mais on est dans
une autre dimension
c'est à dire que non on est on est dans
une vision qui est une vision
manichéenne et sectaires entre exemple
vous autres les entendez votre exemple
on est dans la vision des quatre
évangiles
non non non le vatican n'a pas condamné
le film et pardonnez moi je vous corrige
vous avez dit qu abraham foxman a dit
que le film était antisémite
c'est fort où abraham foxman a dit que
le film n'était pas antisémite mais qui
pouvait sur des esprits simples
peut-être éveillé de l'antisémitisme
attention autre exemple tarak autre
exemple le diable il ya s'attend dans ce
film où il est toujours du côté des
juifs c'est à dire à chaque fois mais
pour sa journée par une femme louis ce
qui est déjà très curieux d'avoir
d'ajouter
alami une forme de misogynie c'est la
première fois a soudain pourquoi est-ce
que tout à coup sortant des évangiles le
diable serait une femme mais attendez
vous venez de dire tout à l'heure c'est
une oeuvre d'un metteur en scène et
calais personnel vous êtes réalisateur
met absolument tout fait des oeuvres
personnelles
à voir maintenant refaire le film
pourquoi ben je vais vous laisser le
temps est toujours du côté des juifs il
ya bonjour d'abord ils sont à sa
carrière
mais d'abord ils sont tous juifs
pardonnez moi tout le monde est juif
dans le film sauf les romains dont vous
voulez vous qu'ils passent ou parmi les
romains ou parmi les juifs tarak ben
léger que je dise le fond de ma pensée
mais j'espère je pense que ce film
reprend tout un tas de clichés
antisémites ou plutôt anti judaïque qui
avait été abolie
à l'époque devant tic en deux par jean
xxiii en 1965 le crime de déicide le
pape à l'époque a dit il n'est pas
question de considérer des juifs comme
les délits side
le pape jean paul ii quelques années
après et est allé dans une synagogue à
rome pour demander pardon pour faire
repentance et j'ai l'impression que ce
film finalement nous ramène avant 25 ans
de kick il annuler 50 ans d'efforts de
réconciliation chez plon reproche que je
lui fais finalement 50 ans d'efforts de
réconciliation entre les juifs et les
chrétiens et vous n'avez pas vu dans le
film l'amour
si le pardon la compassion la grâce la
spiritualité s'ils n'ont pas que tu es
un dieu ils ont tué un homme
pardonnez-moi jésus ici il n'y a pas eu
d incident
ils ont tué un homme c'est après qu'on a
dit que c'était un dieu mais à l'époque
c'était un homme
et si c'était un dieu il serait pas mort
il se serait sauvé même lui fait appel à
dieu pour le sauver
donc excusez moi bien sûr je respecte
votre opinion mais mel gibson a dit je
reconnais vatican ii et le justement il
ne reconnaît pas à mon avis le problème
de mel gibson c'est qu'ils les
intégristes comme monseigneur lefebvre
était et est intégriste d'ailleurs jeu
c'est à dire qu'il est d'avant vatican 2
c'est à dire que pour lui finalement il
en est resté à l' à l'appréciation
d'avant c'est à dire les juifs sont un
peuple déicide et on doit pas se
réconcilier
alors que le pas par bien reconnu jean
paul ii la filiation qui avait entre
la religion juive et la religion
catholique mais j'ai un seul coup on les
oppose de nouveau gêné je vous ai des
efforts qui ont été faits depuis 50 ans
sont annihilés par ce film c'est le gros
reproche que je n'y fait après j'ai
plein de compliments à lui faire alors
ni vous ni moi nous représentons le
vatican ouais si ce que vous dites est
vrai vous ne pensez pas que le vatican
après vatican ii avec le poids que porte
le vatican sur le conflit entre les
juifs et les chrétiens comme vous avez
dit qu'ils ont voulu apaiser tout ça
pour effet une déclaration de
dénonciation du film le vatican non
seulement a soutenu le film mais en
italie le vatican a obtenu qu'il n'y ait
aucune interdiction
je veux juste dire une chose on attaque
on était à la genèse d'un siècle qui
risque d'être extrêmement tourmente
malraux lundi sera un siècle de religion
ça ne sera pas la responsabilité de
certains ados vous dont moi dont thierry
dans des zones qui sont des zones de
rapport avec le public est aujourd'hui
non pas de faire partie de ceux qui vont
attiser les haines entre les communautés
mais de faire partie de ceux au
contraire qu'ils vont rappeler que les
mais les communautés et surtout les
trois religions du livre puisqu'il ya un
chrétien et juif est un musulman ici les
trois religions du livre son lait mais
planté dans la même terre et sont les
mêmes et ont le même dieu je pense qu'il
ya danger
surtout quand on est un homme comme vous
allez du côté de ceux qui peuvent être
sectaire
alors d'abord mon pointage que dit elie
chouraqui je partage également ses idées
sur les religions et nous avons le
moindre point de vue puisqu'il vient lui
c'est un juif arabe et moi je suis un
arabe juif critères alors vous savez sur
ceux des bas salaires stérile mais c'est
la vérité je ne suis pas d'accord sur
l'interprétation du film et je ne suis
pas d'accord qu'il n'y a pas des scènes
d'amour y est à 8 flash back dans le
film on voit jésus pardonner parler
d'amour et dire des mais c est déjà là
alors j'allais vous le dire je
voilà ce qu'on n'a pas dit au sujet de
ce film à mon sens on a dit plein de
choses
ce qu'on n'a pas dit c'est qu'au-delà de
son anti judaïsme dix ans voire
antisémitisme il a porté le message du
christ et ça je suis d'accord ça n'a pas
été dit par les journalistes et dire
qu'il a tout un tas de flashback où
jésus dit aimez vous les uns les autres
qui sont grands messages à un moment il
dit vous aimez vos proches vous détestez
vos ennemis c'est facile d'aimer ses
proches puisqu'ils vous est ce qui est
difficile c'est d'aimer ses ennemis et
pardonner à ses ennemis donc ça c'est
très positif ça c'est ce que je trouve
de plus positif dans le film et je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas dit sarah que
je suis un passionné de jésus je trouve
que c'est le l'inde est l'un des fils
préféré de dieu si ce n'est pas son fils
en tout cas pour moi c'est l'un des fils
préféré de dieu je trouve que cette
l'image de cet homme qui a donné son
corps et sa souffrance pour l'humanité
est une des images les plus belles de
l'histoire de l'humanité
pourquoi en avoir fait cette espèce de
chose
monstrueusement violente peut-être parce
que l' empire romain était violent
justement l'ambassade deuxième reproche
qui a été fait au film le premier c'est
l'antisémitisme en a parlé le deuxième
c'est la violence les gens étaient
choqués par cette espèce de péplum gore
jésus est passé à tabac dès son
arrestation
ce qui n'est pas le cas face qui est pas
en tous les cas les écritures safran saf
et de lille dans les évangiles ça dure
20 minutes à l'écran mais bien la vision
vous avez reconnu pour ses la vision
d'un metteur en scène c'est vrai
d'accord les flèches d'argent mais les
flagellations qui dure 20 minutes
alors je peux vous corriger oui les
plans nous voyons jésus flageller et sur
la croix dure huit minutes la
crucifixion deux minutes et demie la
flagellation cinq et demi
ensuite les plans sur les romains sur
les sur le sang sur le public mais sur
lui 8 minutes et vous connaissez la
puissance de l'image vous savez ce
qu'elle peut signifier 7e on a
l'impression que ce pauvre homme
entreprenant pendant deux heures en
prend mais au delà de ce qu'un homme
peut subir
il est exactement ce qu'il a subi
on décrit dans le prophète isaïe qu'il
était comme un agneau à l'abattoir et
qu'il était tellement d'y figurer par la
violence des romains et vous croyez que
les romains au niveau de la flagellation
de la crucifixion
ils s'amusaient mais les romains à
l'époque avant jésus-christ il jeter les
bébés dans les poubelles
alors oui pourquoi maintenant taravella
mars cours sur la violence et score sur
la violence et que les romains je parle
des reproches qui ont été faits au film
premier reproche l'antisémitisme
deuxième reproche la violence troisième
reproche pas c est qu troisième reproche
troisième recroise les critiques mais
c'est encore là alors là ça devient
parfaitement subjectif c'est les
critiques des cinéphiles qui disent que
c'est pas un bon film mais ça je me
permettrais pas de juger parce que c'est
l'oeuvre d'un moteur mais alors la pièce
vous qui êtes cinéaste est ce que vous
pensez que c'est un bon film sur le plan
cinéphilique ou non moi je trouve que me
lisa est un merveilleux metteur en scène
je trouve que c'est un problème du film
c'est qu'il arrive à montrer des choses
avec une force incroyable c'est un bon
metteur en scène c'est tout le danger
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que j'aurais
tellement aimé qu'il met son talent au
service non pas de ce que lui enseigner
son père c'est à dire ceux son père qui
est un révisionniste qui a fait des
déclarations sur son père a dit
alexandre et attend d'être onze juges le
film où le pen
j'en ai je ne
mais ce ne sont pas des procès non mais
c'est très intéressant quand je dis pas
qu'il faut faire un procès au fisc ans
que le père avait dit que vatican ii
c'était un complot maçonnique financé
par les juifs et même si c'est un film
d'avant vatican ii les mel gibson a
répondu en direct à la télévision
américaine sur ce point je reconnais
vatican ii il s'est dissocié de son père
mais comme je regarde son film ci
reconnaît vatican ii c'est ça que je
comprends parlement vous allez demander
au vatican
vous allez aller au vatican lors posé la
question moi j'y suis allé et ils ont
reconnu le film et ils ne l'ont pas
dénoncé
donc ce plan cinéphilie que vous en
pensez quoi non je répète c'est un homme
qui a un qui a du talent il des images
qui sont très belles dents de scie mais
plus beaux plans où j'ai vu dans le film
c'est le plan ou marie embrasse les
pieds de son fils parce que c'est un
plan qui m'a réconcilié avec pendant un
instant avec mel gibson sais je me suis
dit voilà cet homme comprend l'amour
filial donc s'il comprend l'amour entre
une une main et sont enfin il peut
comprendre l'amour entre un homme jésus
est et le reste de l'humanité entre
l'humanité et dieu mais j'ai eu
tellement j'aime et j'ai attendu deux
heures ce plan avant qu'il n'arrive donc
quand il est arrivé effectivement j'ai
été soulagé alors d'abord la chose la
plus importante c'est la fin du film
c'est le pardon de jésus c'est le pardon
pour ses ennemis c'est ce qu'ils prient
pour plusieurs de pardonner à ses amis
de rabat qui commencent à comprendre que
peut-être c'est un homme pieux qui est
sûre cette croix y prie pour lui je vais
rejoindre elie chouraqui
moi j'ai pris ce film non pas pour
ouvrir les plis entre les communautés
au contraire la violence de ce film vous
d'y arrêter la violence
j'suis pas la violence de ce film
démontre que l'intégrisme que
l'intolérance que l'aveuglément des
foules que l'interprétation d'un homme
politique pilates ou de quelques rabbins
contre un autre rabbin
car jésus était un rabbin peut amener à
la mort un homme innocent dans une
cruauté insupportable
et qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est l'islam qui est
intolérante et qui tuent au nom d'un soi
disant livre interprétée par certains
barbu qui se disent connaître mieux
l'islam
il y à des intégristes religieux
catholiques vouloir vous en avait parlé
il y a des rabbins intégristes et
l'icône est bien là et moi aussi
son message les dix commandements ça
c'est une oeuvre où nous avons vu les
juifs les arabes les chrétiens je ne
suis pas sûr que la violence de ce film
soit négatif au contraire elle réveille
les consciences vous savez pourquoi le
jour ce film est sorti on a vu haïti on
a vu madrid
on est donc touché par une réalité et on
ne souffre que pour nos morts
eh bien peut-être que ça va donner envie
aux gens de réfléchir que depuis deux
mille ans
les religions sont manipulés les rues
gili gens sont mal interprétés et
qu'avec cette intolérance
on tue on torture qui a du sens mais
qu'est ce que voulez qu'il y ait dans
une crucifixion
c'est un gars dit mel gibson il a choisi
sa louis lacroix que vous avez dans vos
églises avec un peu de sang ici est un
peu de sang ici regardez l'horreur que
c'était et regardez ce que faisait les
romains et c'est les romains qui le font
et j'ai fait appel aux musulmans de
france
ne tombez pas dans l'erreur
d'antisémitisme car celui qui est
antisémite et anti arabes
les arabes et les juifs sont les fils
d'abraham j'ai fait la bible il a fait
les dix commandements il sait d'autres
fois je parle moi je suis pour que des
films réveille les communautés c'est
peut-être un peu trop réveiller et ben
jamais assez trop un haut karabagh
sauf que gibson la chance d'avoir un
distributeur comme ça parce que eux
mêmes qui défendent
le film d'un metteur en scène comme l'on
jugerait non les nominations que j'ai
eus je jour vivent avec les juifs
catholiques je l'étais à l'école
catholique le jeu ce soit je ne peux pas
croire je vous connais que vous n'ayez
pas en ayant un regard objectif sur ce
film que vous n'ayez pas un moment donné
tremblay en vous disant il est allé trop
loin et ce film ne reflète pas ce qu'ils
devraient refléter je ne le crois pas
maintenant je vais vous dire comment
j'ai réagi quand j'ai vu le film d'avant
j'étais très ému parce que j'ai vu des
vieux rabbin qui ont rien compris à
jésus comme des vieux moufti qui
condamne rouchdi comme des vieux prêtre
qui condamne des jeunes prêtres
j'ai vu des gens parce qu'il porte une
barbe et qui pensent qu'ils ont la robe
qu'ils ont le message de dieu
le message de dieu c'est l'amour la
compassion la fraternité dans les trois
religions et des individus illuminés
dans le monde se permet de tuer au nom
de ces religions et ben ces rabbins à
l'époque on condamner jésus
spirituellement pas physiquement et ça
dans la bible c'est vrai vous le savez
et lee vous savez qu'il voulait s'en
débarrasser
et vous savez qu'ils auraient à pilate
donc qu'est-ce qu'elle fait gérable à
montrer le résultat de ce que ces
rabbins on veut lui éliminé sera minc et
le radis en deux mots vous êtes des
vieux vous êtes vous avez rien compris
voilà ce qu'a dit le banc du met ces
rabat raconte a mené pratiquement 2
millions de comptes internes et les
croisades c'est tout ce message là toute
cette structure mentale là à monter les
communautés les unes contre les autres
et je pense que thierry loncq l'ardhis
on nous disait la vérité quand il a dit
ce ce film est un film d'avant vatican
moi je pense qu'on a rouvert une plaie
pour conclure je dis encore une fois que
ce qu'on n'a pas dit sur le film et ça
je le dis c'est que ce film contient le
message d'amour du christ et ne serait
ce que pour ça il faut aller le voir ne
serait-ce que pour juger d'abord que
dire juste une dernière chose j'aurais
juste que les jeunes gens surtout les
jeunes gens qui vont aller voir ce film
se rappelle encore que c'est la vision
d'un metteur en scène que c'est sa façon
de voir les choses que cet homme est
particulier qu'il a une histoire
particulière
qu'il faut connaître son histoire pour
comprendre ce qu'il a fait 2-2 ce
parcours de jésus et je voudrais faire
appel aux millions de personnes qui
voient l'émission de thierry ardisson
surtout ne pensez pas que les quelques
rabbins qu'il ya 2000 ans on condamner
jésus sont les juifs d'aujourd'hui comme
les italiens aujourd'hui ne sont pas les
capots romains qui ont flageller
crucifié jésus
donc nous ne transmettons pas de père en
fils les horreurs du passé
est-ce que les turcs d'aujourd'hui sont
les turcs du génocide arménien et je
pourrais continuer comme ça sans
m'arrêter drague donc comme ça nous
avait lieu mais non c'est vrai j'aurais
aimé voir ce que vous dites dans le film
allez-y pour vous faire votre avis
[Musique]
ben ahmed
amy choix qui est le bon soir alors
avant de passer à votre prochain
spectacle quelques mails un
téléspectateur qui aimerait savoir si
vous avez un lien de parenté avec les
jackson five ou si vous êtes juste fan
j'ai un lien avec les juifs
un autre volet savoir s'il suite au
succès des dix commandements vous avez
reverser de l'argent mackay a écrit la
bible
oui j'ai lu et fait une concession
advitam eternam un autour de savoir si
c'est plus facile de rater un film ou
une comédie musicale
c'est facile de rater les 2 1 c'est pas
facile de rater un film moi j'ai essayé
je suis pas rien
[Applaudissements]
alors édition acquis quatre ans après le
triomphe des dix commandements 2
millions d'albums vendus 2 millions de
singles 2 millions de spectateurs
vous revenez pour mettre en scène un
nouveau spectacle musical qui s'appelle
gladiateurs il révèle être libre parole
et musique de maxime le forestier ça
sort le 1er octobre 2004 au palais des
sports de paris
[Musique]
seul
alors c'est l'histoire de spartacus ça
se passe dans la rome antique alors là
c'est bien avant jésus-christ ses 73 ans
avant jésus-christ et c'est un esclave
qui est devenu gladiateur qui s'élèvent
contre sa condition est contraint consul
devenu dictateur qui s'appelle grâce us
c'est un nom prédestiné partie du
premier le triumvirat 26 à pomper cra
voulons absolument vous dire que c'est
aussi ça la culture ancestrale qui
s'était pas c'est pas un intello
spécialement un nom certains religieux
non plus c'est un jeune traces qui a été
on dit qu'il a été mercenaire du qu'il
était paysan
en tout cas il a été pris par les
romains il a été envoyé dans les mines
de nubie là où la chaleur est écrasante
où on devait couper le marbre et peu
d'hommes résister il a été pris part il
a été repéré comme un casting directeurs
vers un acteur par un homme il
s'appelait batiatus qui l'a emmené à
capoue qui était la plus grande école de
gladiateurs et il en a fait une machine
à tuer et ce qu'a refusé spartacus c'est
le fait de devoir tuer ou vivre il ay là
il a pris conscience qu'il ne pouvait
pas admettre 7,7 ce destin et il sait
révolte il entraîner c'est un homme très
charismatique qui les entraînait avec
lui ses hommes qui étaient glacials
normes et 600000 armée d'abord les
gladiateurs ensuite six cent mille
esclaves de tout de tout de toute
l'italie deux tours hommes ne sont venus
le rejoindre
c'est le symbole de l'homme contre quoi
l'homme qui se lèvent seul contre tous
c'est l'homme qui a conceptualisé les
droits de l'homme
c'est le premier qui a dit tous les
hommes sont libres et égaux en droit il
ne savait pas encore que ce serait la
base de nos sociétés démocratiques
mais en tout cas il a osé un mendiant
moi je suis légal de crassus je suis
légale des romains je ne suis pas un
sous-homme je suis comme je suis un
homme et je suis un homme aussi
important que n'importe quel homme
[Musique]
et les choix qui regardez votre caméra
est dit magnéto c'est magnéto serge
il y aura des hommes riches jeudi
et
et puis j'ai
en qu'il y aura des chaînes
des fouets
des prisons jeu
je
ouais je reviendrai
dans les musiques de maxime le forestier
mise en scène d'elie chouraqui qu'est
notre invité ce soir et c'est le 1er
octobre 2004 palais des sports voilà
alors on en reparlera mais en tout cas
c'est une aventure extraordinaire encore
qui commence pour vous édition accueille
1 c'est une qui est extraordinaire c'est
de voir les énergies venant de toutes
parts qui s'associent pour faire ce
spectacle les chanteurs toute la troupe
les danseurs les gens il faut les
costumes les décors
je trouve que c'est ça et moi c'est ce
que j'ai vécu avec les dix commandements
et c'est pour ça que j'ai eu en plus du
thème que j'ai que j'ai trouvé autour
spartacus j'ai eu envie de faire un
nouveau spectacle c'est que j'ai vécu
une aventure humaine d'une dimension que
je n'avait sans doute jamais vécu même
dans un métier que j'adore qui est le
cinéma
alors voilà ensuite vous tournerez ô
jérusalem d'après le roman de lapierre
et collins que nous recevrons tout à
l'heure pour leur dernier livre new york
brûle-t-il
ils ont quand même vendu 10 millions
d'exemplaires de jérusalem c'est
l'histoire de la fondation de l'état
d'israël après la décision de de l'onu
et puis vous allez jusqu'à la guerre de
1948 qui est leur guerre entre les
israéliens et les palestiniens
si vous les jeux j'ai pensé que pour
aider à aider essayer de mettre une
petite pierre peut aider à résoudre ce
conflit en tout cas l'antagonisme qu'il
peut y avoir entre les communautés
encore une fois en france et dans le
monde
il fallait expliquer la genèse du
conflit fallait bien on expliquer que ce
n'est pas d'aider des juifs venant des
camps de concentration qui ont pris une
terre qui appartenaient à des
palestiniens
c'est que la palestine était un
protectorat anglais qui suivait une
dictature dictature turquie avait dû
appuyer centaines d'années et qu'en fait
qu'est nations unies ont décidé dans
cette danse protectorat de faire deux
états un état juif et un état
palestinien pour que ces deux états
vivent l'un à côté de l'autre en paix et
phase peut-être le rêve absolu lutte au
pied absolu les états unis du
moyen-orient alors évidemment ce conflit
du moyen orient et importer ici
vous le dites dans le documentaire que
vous avez fait pour pour envoyé spécial
et c'est tout le problème c'est qu'il
faut expliquer aux gens c'est un conflit
territorial avec ce n'est pas un conflit
ethnique ou religieux et qu'il faut pas
l'importer ici je crois que c'est aussi
ce que c'est toute la manade des
intéristes à dire que les extrémistes
veulent justement que ce conflit soit
exporté comme un conflit ethnique
on fit religieux c'est l'islam contre la
judaïté
ce n'est pas ça ce que vivent au
quotidien les palestiniens à gaza et en
cisjordanie
le drame des palestiniens s'est aussi
d'une certaine façon le drame des
israéliens dans leur majorité
même si parfois le gouvernement va te
contre cette majorité
ce qu'ils vivent c'est un conflit
territorial ils essaient chacun de
trouver une place pour vivre alors c'est
une situation assez difficile il faut
avoir beaucoup de sagesse et faire peu
d'excès je vais vous faire les choix qui
une interview inxs
[Musique]
est-ce que par excès de colère vous
pourriez coller une baffe un de vos
gosses oui est-ce que par excès de
jalousie
vous avez déjà dénigrer un film que vous
saviez être bon non est-ce que par excès
de l'acheter vous êtes déjà excusé
devant un mec qui vous avez insultés non
est-ce que par excès de feignantise vous
êtes déjà manger des chips sur un canapé
oui est-ce que par excès de perversité
vous avez déjà fait l'amour en vous
regardant dans un miroir n'ont même pas
une petite partie de tomas enge il parle
j'y passais plus j'ai pas eu ce fantasme
là non est-ce que par excès des
infidélités vous pourriez tromper votre
maîtresse avec votre femme non est-ce
que par excès de cheveux vous vous êtes
déjà passé de rayer pour dormir
il
non non je dors avec deux araignées 6-3
et fait pas confiance aux cheveux pour
la musique n'a pas envie parlant t'as
pas envie de changer de coupe parfois
j'ai essayé la tienne d'accord et moi
j'ai un truc à proposer et j'ai trouvé
un truc qui pourrait changer
radicalement
c'est la même chose
ces paramètres mais moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est une femme et la mère
celle à m alors laurent et il sera
question à qui bon soir qu est-ce que
par excès de mauvaise foi vous êtes déjà
essayé de faire croire que c'est vous
qui aviez rédiger les dix commandements
non non surtout pas tirer je te propose
d'essayer ya pas de raison au nom ici
pour voir l'effet chouraqui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant s'il était président
l'homme
j'ai voulu
voici la ligue 2 juin
[Musique]
bonsoir et les saints
et mme bigot selon bonsoir ça on s'en
tirer je crois qu'il faut dire elodie
gossuin chouraqui
jamais
la vraie révélation c'est qu'en fait
cette coupe va tout le monde croyait que
ça ne parlait pas alors que ça va tout
le monde savait le dit très bien
elodie gossuin 1 m 78 80 quoi à la 81 81
vous avez grandi donc 85 85 cm de tour
de poitrine 90 90 jeun sans bonnet e
s'en sort sans cinq mois d'arrêt c'est
pas exactement les mensurations c'est
moins 85
non c'est pas un peu plus un peu plus 90
90 et tour de taille 70 à soissons les
hanches 90 kg 85 j'ai pris un peu aussi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé elle a pris du
cul ça arrive aux meilleurs
elle a dit non tu sais qui est le sien
et conseillère générale 2
conseiller régional de picardie de morts
et qu'il faut faire attention à la
picardie maintenant j'ai peur maintenant
sept
vous êtes une élue maintenant oui je
suis très fier de l'être alors
l'histoire d'elodie gossuin tout le
monde la connaît d'abord reine du muguet
accompli
c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
ensuite en pignon à mélodie suit la
progression inexorable me sers pèse 80
c'est à cause du tibet cet homme et
ventriloque ce ne sont pas mes vannes
ensuite miss oise à gouvieux ensuite
miss picardie ensuite miss france miss
europe mais pas miss univers puisque à
l'élection à porto rico
un quotidien de san juan la capitale de
porto rico comme vous le savez avait
annoncé que vous étiez un homme ça pour
ça pour une couille qui sont là dit
souvent c'est la vie est injuste c'est
un truc quand fait qu'ils étaient sur
internet c'est un site internet c'est le
fameux site internet où on disait que
jean luc delarue avait deux pénis non
mais c'est vrai actuellement alors que
ce jeu c'est pas vrai c'est je pense pas
ouais voilà alors malgré tout ça était
5e dauphine à miss univers c'est déjà
pas mal parce que c'est déjà ça
c'est grand bah oui c'est grand
l'univers voilà alors c'est un peu comme
en picardie vous n'avez pas été élu mais
vous êtes quand même cinquième sur la
liste d'être la cinquième dauphine de
gilles de robien ont calqué ses rangs
quelques sword est toujours cinquième
dauphine bon ben voilà alors comme vous
êtes devenue conseillère régionale ça
vous a déçu de pas avoir de dia des
mélodies n'ont absolument pas et est
tout autre chose y avait aucun rapport
bien sûr avec toutes les élections de
miss et c'était un autre engagement une
autre motivation parce que je me sens
profondément picarde c'était plus pour
ma région
enfin pour un parti mais pour eux mais
pour un homme pour gilles car je me
rends pas compte moi parce que moi j'ai
toujours grandi dans cette région et
j'adore cette région c'est bien cette
région picardie en décembre 9h20 des
envies de mort
et c'est la petite venise c'est joli
mais voilà gilles de robien vous
demandez défilent en maillot non pas du
tout il a beaucoup de respect pour vous
gilles de robien sens plus fort barrage
alors finalement la politique c'est pas
tellement différent de miss france nom
d'une certaine façon je pense que la vie
de miss m'a préparé à la vidéo toujours
pour la paix dans le monde comme quand
vous étiez nice jamais déclarer sa
réponse aux questions dit toujours que
c'est mal de tuer des animaux pour faire
des manteaux
on vous demande toujours de sourire
toute la journée comme quand vous étiez
mise finalement c'est assez naturel
qu'on m'a jamais essayé de le faire
alors la droite bon ben c'est fait
bananer je crois que c'est terrible ce
qui s'est passé on a parlé d'un 21 avril
à l'envers
ouais bah c'est sûr que c'est dommage
parce que je pense effectivement que les
gens n'ont pas fait un vote régional
dans certaines régions je suis d'accord
effectivement qu'en fonction des
attentes des gens je pense que peut-être
pas de responsabilité dans ces réseaux
comme si moi je pense que oui parce que
vous n'avez pas vraiment aidé la droite
avait déclaré elodie gossuin que
ségolène royal vous l'admirent y est
profondément que c'était une femme
politique que vous admiriez le plus j'ai
dit que c'était une femme que j'admire
énormément et je ne regrette pas ce que
j'ai dit c'est bien dans la droite se
met à dire que l'école a raison je sens
bien je suis d'accord j'ai 23 ans et
bien sûr que je rêve d'avoir une vie
comme la sienne aussi épanouie d'après
françois hollande et une vie c'est pas
forcément une ambition est d'avoir une
vie de femme aussi panique la sienne
bien sûr que moi 23 ans est ce que je
rêve là vous pensez que j'évite femme
épanouie oui je pense avoir quatre
enfants pour moi déjà c'est ces voix là
bas mais françois hollande je parle pas
de français mais c'est sur le lit et
c'est françois 42
pense à ça la nuit avant mais maintenant
c'est que vous vous dites que ségolène
royal est une fille formidable
geneviève de fontenay elle dit qu'il
faut voter pour avec la guinée donc à la
rédaction vous aidez pas beaucoup la
droite l'a quand même hein mais je en
aucun cas j'ai soutenu geneviève dans
tout l'est tous les chronos les
interviews qu'elle a pu donner avant moi
ma candidature j'ai jamais dit que
j'étais parce que j'ai deux comités miss
france que j'avais même opinion que je
n'ai en aucun cas et si vous croyez que
la france a besoin d'un retour de jeu ce
pas non je ne pense pas vous croyez que
hollande ferait un bon premier ministre
je ne pense pas vous croyez que les 35
heures finalement c'est vachement bien
c'est assez mitigé j'ai une opinion
assez mitigée sur les 35 heures je pense
qu'il ya du positif quand même la tête
je rentre trop dans le détail ce qu'on
pourrait un peu plus léger ce qu'ils
vont faire au conseil général c'est
qu'il aura le bouton oui le bouton non
et puis je tombe je sais pas au milieu
peut-être n'ont pas facilité la tâche
peut-être peut-être qu'ils vont être
obligés de faire ouvrir apparente 3
c'est cuit avant même de commencer je
dirais pas ça j'ai dû en espoirs mais
effectivement on recommence un peu avec
les mêmes mais moi je suis très fier que
gilles de robien garder son ministère
parce que c'est un homme formidable
à part ça donc j'ai bientôt publier un
livre sur votre aventure miss france
miss europe chez michel lafon qui
s'appelle aventure érotique d'une
coquine libertine
non j'ai la [ __ ] au diadème avant
moi j'avais les aventures érotiques du
cockpit
des sérieuses à mobiliser si vous avez
raconté ça les histoires d'amour d'une
demi seconde à n'ont absolument pas je
parle de mon rêve de miss france et de
miss europe
est ce que j'ai vécu pendant l'année ce
que moi j'ai vécu c'est vraiment mon
rêve à moi je vais faire un disque aussi
là bas si c'est bien prévu c'est pas
prévu mon âge et qui l'avait fait
renoncer bien non elle ne pousse pas non
plus c'est bien mais pas faire un des
sinon c'est pas important déjà des dj
pas faire un disque séparé il ya eu une
proposition mais pour l'instant je
pourrais vous le faites pas et parce que
je peux pas tout faire en même temps et
pas exceptionnellement la chanson est
très belle c'est un rêve aussi pour plus
tard effectivement quand vous serez
ministre
[Musique]
vous auriez bien chanteuse aussi en fait
vous avez beaucoup trop de qualités
finalement quoi être miss france pour
être miss poitau et puis à la ferme
aussi la ferme des célébrités sur tf1
vous allez y aller je ne sais pas j'ai
été contacté mais pour l'instant cette
décision pourquoi vous hésité parce que
j'ai effectivement la priorité je viens
d'être élu conseiller régional et pour
moi c'est l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est
bien payé quand même un a effectivement
mais bon j'ai jamais été attirés que par
l'argent mais elle a surtout été tirée
dans la caisse moi mais j'ai
effectivement le dérangeait pas de
problème d'argent j'ai la chance de voir
faire des choix par rapport à ce qui me
correspond vraiment j'ai pas le choix de
l'argent facile je fais le choix de deux
du domaine dans lequel je m'épanouis
manière générale mais s'il voulait
amener votre caniche
je sais pas c'est d'être alors alors on
reviendra car il pas un truc de
prostitution
bizarre cette histoire on revient à la
politique devant l'ampleur de la crise
que traverse notre pays on a besoin de
toutes les bonnes volontés
donc on va faire le dis que tu as une
interview au boulot
elodie gossuin donc maintenant vous êtes
dans la politique vous êtes au conseil
régional de picardie
quelle part du budget de la région
picarde faut-il attribuer à la culture
normalement c'est environ 60 millions de
francs pour moi 60 millions
c'est bien dit dans ça en fait des
danses folkloriques avec jean pierre
pernaut le dimanche avec jean-pierre
bien sûr un plaisir
pensez vous que le combat des
intermittents soit juste moi je pense
qu'il est fondée mais après je n'ai
jamais côtoyé plus précisément que ça le
milieu des intermittents pour pouvoir
savoir dans quelles conditions de
travail c'est pas que je me doute bien
mais c'est vrai que je suis pas je peux
pas être juge de tout ça parce que je
suis vous êtes obligée là quand même à
un moment non mais non parce que j'ai
jamais prétendu quoi que ce soit je n'ai
pas la prétention de dire que j'ai été
sur la liste de gilles de robien pour
faire partie de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire ou des
finances je suis là pour faire partie de
la commission d'identité régionale de la
communication par exemple qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour que les vieux
arrête de mourir en étaient les sdf en
hiver votre avis je sais pas plus
d'infrastructures plus de logements
sociaux s'est passé bien nommé dit pas
je sais pas si c'est parce que c'est
exactement ce que disent ceux qui sont
scandaleux dont personne ne parle des
éphémères qu'on ne devrait dit 24 heures
par rapport à par exemple tortues
marines qui peut vite être maintenant
même celle des galapagos en 50 ans vous
pouvez passer injuste google durée de
vie in est éphémère sa vie 24 heures
vous pensez faire clôturer ce courage
donc pour les inondations par exemple
n'avait pas de programme
il n'y a pas de programme mais par
contre je participe à tous qui
associatif sans être conseil régional
j'ai participé à tous les galas au
profit d un dea de la somme il ya trois
ans c'était votre forme de sinistres
sapref exception gentil ce que tu manges
moi je sais mais tu allais m'a dit
déglingue l'aja ne parlerai pas du tout
c'est barbray pas qui veut ni jeu là non
pas du tout elle est mignonne comme tour
laurent tu vas dit c'est un mec je
trouve ça mal jeunes
l'inventeur rien elodie qui veulent vous
voir vous êtes prêt à faire quoi pour
que les beaux jours reviennent par
exemple le plan politique un branchement
il n'y a pas de vrai programme là on a
encore vu récemment qu est ce que vous
avez fait vous la droite pour contre les
giboulées de mars il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de programme avec gilles de
robien et c'est vrai que c'est pas parce
que c'est la télé mais c'est vrai que je
pense sincèrement que c'est pas gilles
de robien qui a perdu les élections mais
que c'est la picardie qui a perdu gilles
de robien vraiment quoi ça va loin là
encore une comédie musicale
et maintenant
[Musique]
voici le luth à piles
lolita pile bonsoir assis devant moi
nombre passer ma perruque
il a essayé vous
[Musique]
d'ailleurs pour les femmes en fait ça
fait un peu cheap kakwata touché un
manche pour être utile à baffier en même
temps non pourquoi boîte n'a pas
embrassé chouaki joly n'a pas ce que je
n'ai jamais croisé avant ah ah oui c'est
comme ça c'est un nom à toi j'ai déjà
croissance et 3 connaissent et de
l'étape il n'en son père m'appelait
lolita pas du tout par perversion mais
parce que le prénom lolita n'était pas
dans le calendrier des saints donc son
père l'a appelé le lutin en fait juste
par anticléricalisme voilà c'est ça
ressemble aux garçons j'ai quand même
et oui oui ça ressemble à la sarre sans
papa
alors c'est frédéric beigbeder qui vous
a donné envie d'écrire à l'oit à pyla je
voyais la littérature comme quelque
chose d'assez sacré jeu sacré des
oeuvres à moi et c'est simplement quand
j'ai lu 99 francs de beigbeder que je me
suis rendu compte que la littérature
était le reflet d'une époque et par un
vieux truc poussiéreux intouchable c'est
là que je me suis dit que je pouvais
peut-être raconter ce que moi j'avais
envie de raconter et que c'était
possible sont les missions sur sur canal
l'hyper chaud ça vous a pas donné envie
de faire la télévision non
votre premier roman s'est bien passé
vous en avez vendu 40 mille exemplaires
elle s'appelait j'en ai vendu pas mal
on en a parlé
il y à l'adaptation qui va se faire au
cinéma
oui ah oui oui et 10 mais on a déjà
bruno chiche ah oui d'où le nom il a dit
oui tout de suite
avec ses dimensions vous avez déclaré je
suis nul à chier la télévision c'est une
catastrophe
j'y vais comme une tomate est en fait
j'avais déjà comme un automate
je veux dire un automate c'est peut-être
le journaliste qui a ajouté un peu par
hasard
ouais ça arrive asile et qu'on les
journalistes franchement vous avez
ajouté si je me retrouve à la télé entre
bigard et diam's je pourrais pas me
retenir de les insulter
j'ai alors les mages est un message de
jean-marie pour nous
alors quand on dit que je ne prépare pas
j'ai surtout fait toujours marrer hier
il m'a fait quelques phrases et donc
pourquoi vous les insultez bigard
télévision non pas du tout mais c'est
vrai que j'ai un peu de mal à
à regarder la télévision aujourd'hui
j'ai un peu de mal avec aussi les
déviances de la culture et
l' espèce de spirale de médiocrité dans
lequel elle s'engouffre en ce moment et
que si belle fille n'était pas là je ne
serais pas une nulle à chier à la télé
je suis venu chez nous lâche et de toute
façon
mais c'est pas grave c'est pas
qu'est ce qu à l envie de baiser on
bosse là
le printemps entrepreneuriale bien se
cacher derrière le filet mais il est
invité mission d'abord tu sais bien
ben mon vieux
non c'est dommage c'est vachement bien
si vous étiez en train de vie en plus je
suis d'accord et qu'elle s'attend dire
que c'est bien ce qu'elle a dit parce
que moi je suis pas qu par séville 23 21
ans 1 et qui viennent là il y en a une
qui conseil régional qui vient d'écrire
un livre et viennent comme celle d'une
espèce d'assurance appelons-le de l'aide
vous répondre avec avec intelligence et
d'envisager toi
non mais
je trouve qu'elle a un mérite un allié
voilà voilà une chanson pour arroser ça
mais je ressente jean marais merci jean
marie
alors maintenant on en arrive bocal
s'appelle de l'album ça peut être adapté
au cinéma c'est pas si chiches
alors le pitch c'est l'histoire d'une
double manipulation qui m'a fait peur ok
service le bk morts double manipulation
laurent alors la manipulation c'est
d'abord celle d'une jeune provinciale
qui s'appelle manon qui est prête à tout
pour devenir célèbres qui rencontre un
jeune milliardaire blasé oisif qui
s'appelle derek est là juste pour le fun
se dérègle ce milliardaire décide de
bousiller la vie de manon il lui
fabrique une réussite en carton pâte
avant de la renvoyer vers l'anonymat
voilà ça c'est la première manipulation
la deuxième manipulation je ne dirais
pas évidemment faut lire le livre sinon
tu es là même si on sait qu'on sinon à
quoi ça sert que tu te sois décarcasser
pendant des mois et des semaines pour
écrire ce livre au regard des sondages
et donner un petit peu envie aux gens
mais c'est vrai après je dis pas la
deuxième manipulation qui est encore
mieux que que la première balle a alors
on la voit ses sept manon au début dans
son bled de province elle déteste sa vie
elle rêve de monter à paris elle finit
par le faire
en fait ma non c'est une c'est une jeune
fille qui est qui a l'impression d'avoir
été laissés pour compte
ce n'est pas qu'ils ne se retrouvent pas
dans son époque son problème ce n'est
pas de vivre en provence et d'être
serveuse ce n'est pas si terrible
son problème c'est que après le boulot
elles montrent s'enferme dans sa chambre
elle lit des magazines elle regarde mtv
et l impression que c'est ça la vraie
vie voilà il ya une trace formidable
elle rêve d'une vie où on vivait la nuit
où on roulait trop vite ou en mourrait
trop tôt une belle phrase énoncée des
noms mais c'est bien laurent non mais
c'est vrai il ya quelques phrases comme
ça exactement et donc elle elle rêve
de cette vie dont elle a l'impression
que c'est l'unique digne d'être vécue
et elle monte à paris pour la conquérir
et pour conquérir le monde
elle ne trouve pas d'autre moyen que de
devenir une star parce que devenir une
star aujourd'hui ça paraît tellement
évident tellement simple tellement
facile il suffit de bombarder une image
pendant quelques mois la télévision pour
que
des millions de spectateurs vous scotche
vous regarde vous un prime vous
reconnaissent et la célébrité
voilà et c'est l'unique moyen qu'elle
trouve pour pour gagner de l'argent pour
prendre place dans la société de
consommation
sauf que ça se passe pas bien du tout
parce que quand elle refuse de coucher
avec le patron de l' agence de pub elle
se retrouve serveuse dans un bistrot et
elle couche dans une chambre de bonne
absolument parce que justement j'ai pas
écrit ce livre pour accabler les jeunes
filles qui avaient envie de gloire parce
que je ne pense pas que qu'elle soit
digne d'être accablé
ce sont plus des victimes que
que d'ignobles petit arriviste elles
sont victimes évidemment des médias
d'une image que les médias leur envoi de
cette espèce de facilité de cette espèce
de monde miraculeux qui n'existent pas
parce que toutes les photos sont
retouchées la plage miami le surf la mer
les voyages la dolce vita c'est joli sur
une photo c'est pour ça que je
consciemment je ne veux pas qu'elle
couche avec ce producteur c'est à ce
type d' agence de mannequins parce
qu'elle n'est pas vénal tant que ça
allait pas arriviste à l épatant que
s'apprête à comme sa copine qui a une
copine qui s'appelle 6ème copine
totalement anodine en vêtements aux
stars fucker alors elle baise avec des
pipoles et elle croit que c'est lui
donne un droit donc en évitant les
embouteillages après a déjà tourné les
six mois passés parce que elle croit que
le fait de ce fait sauter par puff daddy
ça lui donne le droit de passer devant
les autres c'est un peu aussi la
dénonciation de la télé réalité c'est à
dire ces gosses qu'on fabrique comme ça
pendant quelques mois et qui après se
retrouve tout à fait le milliardaire que
rencontrent ces manants c'était endemol
le dr c'est à dire l incident de faire
d'elle finalement une star mais tout ça
est en carton pâte tout ça est
complètement bidon
exactement c'est à dire que s'ils font
une entité puissante forte et riche tels
que ce garçon que j'ai représenté sous
les traits d'un milliardaire justement
pour lui donner ce pouvoir l'un va
attraper une fille au hasard qu'il va
hisser jusqu'au sommet de la célébrité
qui va faire passer de l'anonymat
l'exposition de la pauvreté à l'extrême
luxe simplement dans son intérêt si
l'intérêt à lui c'est de se désennuyer
l'intérêt
du genre de boîte de production qui font
ça c'est tout simplement le pognon voilà
mais le résultat est le même c'est qu'à
la fin on a une pauvre épave
voilà alors on la retrouve d'ailleurs un
an plus tard un an après sa rencontre
avec ce milliardaire au festival de
cannes dont elle est devenue top model
enfin c'est ce qu'elle croit elle est
complètement diva cocaïnomane et il ya
une soirée où heureusement dit elle n'y
a pas trop de français c'est une soirée
type est devenu très stable à lamanon en
question et elle dit à un moment je vois
une miss france
accompagnée de sa mère maquerelle
enchapeautées voilà et j'aime bien ça
moi c'est le seul truc que j'ai pas aimé
dans le bouquin et goûter je trouvais la
forme c'est pas gentil pour geneviève
qui est une amie quand c'est vrai
qu'elle est drôle et vous savez depuis
je les ai vus à la télévision et je me
suis rendu compte que justement cette
télévision m'avait envoyé une fausse
image d'elle que je la prenais pour une
sorte de grue en chat potté et qu'en
fait elle est assez drôle à un certain
franc-parler et j'avoue que je suis
navré justement d'avoir jugé trop vite
non mais c'est vrai je ne vais pas du
tout comme on a cru non non elle est
très bas tolérante on peut parler de
tout l on peut tout lui confier elle est
vraiment oui c'est vrai que c'est un peu
pour moi une mamie idéale mois donc elle
se retrouve dans cette soirée il ya donc
cette miss france avec sa mère
maquerelle dans sa potée quelques
lofteurs dit vous abandonner tous hébété
dans un coin mais on comprend quelque
chose qui cloche ça c'est intéressant là
je trouvais un côté truman show kéké pas
mal dans votre bouquin est un film chez
bt games aussi ça ressemble un peu à ça
et elle se rend compte qu'en fait
effectivement se dorait qu'à monter tout
ça elle ne s'est pas vraiment en fait
ouais on ne sait pas vraiment quelle est
la part de fantasme est la part de
réalité
s'il a été manipulée ou celle a été
simplement manipulé par elle même et par
ses propres frais
et si son arrivisme ne l'a pas justement
conduite à devenir totalement cinglé
freine érotomane et à s'inventer cette
histoire on n'était même pas des
artistes maudits on n'était pas des
artistes
on était des arrivistes maudit oui oui
c'est parce qu'à un moment donné
donc cette jeune fille connaît donc
grandeur et décadence monte au sommaire
redescend et et là elle va se retrouver
à fréquenter tout une bande de personnes
dont lé a l'impression qu'ils sont un
peu dans le même cas call et qui sont
justement une bande de victime tout
comme elles qui sont victimes de leur
arrivisme de leur ambitieux mais une
ambition qui ne procédait pas d'un
sentiment que moi j'estime être le le
vrai vecteur de quelqu'un qui devient
célèbre c'est à dire on a un domaine où
un art qui nous tient à coeur on est
plus ou moins bon si on y est bon on est
reconnu et après cette reconnaissance
intervient ce qu'on appelle la notoriété
la notoriété qui passe par le cap de la
reconnaissance qui implique un respect
le respect d'un talent et d'un véritable
existence le mérite ça c'est une
célébrité qui peut être revendiquée du
mal à sept kilos l'italie elle a du mal
comment ça se fait jusqu'à peut-être un
peu trop en dire un peu trop tapas et
puis on comprend pas tout est-ce que
vous prouver que votre éditeur va être
content il est dans la logique on va
faire venir et est-ce qu'on peut devenir
manuel carcassonne
[Musique]
ça
maintenant asseyez vous et vous essayez
vous alors vous l'avez trouvé comment
cette fois ci puisque la dernière fois
c'était épouvantable suivi quitte comme
chez poivre d'arvor est ce que cette
carte de bons clients bien sûr est ce
que vous l'avez trouvé mieux cette fois
ci elle était très bien d'ailleurs la
souris ouais vous allez remarquer l
avant elle était un peu revêche et je
lui ai dit faux sourire est large et les
pleurs a compté son bouquin quand même
vous êtes d'accord a été un peu longue
il ya eu un mort un peu loin il est un
peu long et ça y est mais il a été très
dur hein mais il est contré par métier
moi j'étais venu en tyrie non mais lui à
lui oui à l'honneur [ __ ] salut
non franchement voudrait qu'elle va y
arriver un jour franchement à mon nom et
deviendra non non non elle était bien
les tells souriez lll capter la lumière
elle a été un peu longue peut-être mais
dans le désir de bien faire de notre
expliqué max qu elle était moins
[ __ ] que la première fois la guerre
c'est pas une bad girl et la grâce et on
pense même qu'elle est vierge à sa grâce
à l'étranger dès dirigeants début on a
bu n'a pas fait tout seul
séance de ce soir va vendre des livres
manuels ah oui oui mais non là je trouve
que le lite à noël était très timide
notamment ici on était très timide et
hervé schaal avait peur là elle est
éclatante
souriante luxuriante gelabale jusque là
bas l'an telli a été sympa très bien
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
interactive quel est ton prénom bien la
ville il y en a vite je reste à voir
comment tu réagis par rapport à
l'intervention de l'éditeur en faite je
veux qu'il a été très convaincant et il
a eu raison parce qu'elle sait très bien
exprimé j'ai trop hâte y trouve toi
aussi qu'elle s'est bien exprimé à
trouver qualité merci beaucoup
la réaction et les temples et non en
huit ans viendra des gens par rapport à
la réaction de spectateurs précédent à
tout comme on commande de trouver le mec
qui est venu parler de l'éditeur très
sympathique bonne intervention également
bien voilà bien la tienne est bien trop
pas mal également car cela ne sera pas
coupée au montage
non mme banon mais l'attitude en direct
on termine sur bonne comme il ya
quelques belles phrases que beigbeder a
relevé d'ailleurs vous verrez ça donne
toi il n'ya rien de pire que ce moment
où l'on cesse d'avoir envie de grandir
pour commencer à redouter de vieillir
c'est une belle phrase on leur mettra
dans l'autre chacun leurs aidants il ya
une phrase aussi que j'aime bien c'est
elle boit comme un trou pour oublier
qu'elle s'est trompée de rêve
c'est assez joli c'est assez morale un
finalement une fable c'est une fable
morale finalement sur la confusion des
shebab
c'est en fait c'est un anti conte de
fées whissell ça et maintenant
m
ah ah
[Musique]
j'accueille les deux
bien oui ça coupe le souffle comme ça
tout lisent très impressionnant encore
de jean marie bigard là bas les filles
ça va très bien merci
qu'est-ce qu'il irait d'une pause bis
rue rang parce que si on n'appelle pas
là la confusion c'est le moment de faire
la malle exanet ratant un virage à
nelson à fabien barthez venu non si on
ne profite pas aujourd'hui leur en fera
jamais vous les connaissez lycée jeune
fille non je les connais pas encore mais
bon et laquelle tu as préféré
je refuse ce genre de questions
auxquelles nous allons procéder à son
exclusion je veux dire au revoir au
groupe tu vas quitter l'île des baléares
pourquoi là je veux faire la pause
bisous bisous à la ben j'aime quand tu
veux mais je l'aimerais faire une pause
bisous
non
c'est
d'un passing
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
joke alors je vais faire le pitch la
population ah ah
j'expliquais munichois qui pourquoi ces
jeunes filles sont là parce qu'on fait
c'est bizarre d'avoir toutes ces jolies
filles de la télé réalité comme jeune
fille pourquoi elle est choquée la cause
de gladiateurs son nouveau spectacle le
1er octobre 2004 au palais des sports à
paris voilà c'est ça voilà bien alors
les plus belles filles de la télé
réalité relève un défi hors du commun
s'agit récente comment j'ai filmé la
nuit dans les entrepôts le corps enduit
d'huile
tu vas voir c'est de la merde et elle se
bat deux par deux le but c'est de
plaquer les épaules de son adversaire au
sol pendant au moins trois secondes elle
se bat oui oui
son format ainsi chichi deux jours et
deux nuits de tournage toi qui de la
profession qui sait ce que ça veut dire
the string déchiré je crois qu'à 180
minutes d'image et avant de regarder à
quoi ça ressemble on va rappeler qu'ils
vous êtes d'abord on a commencé avec
alexandra donc vous êtes la gagnante du
bachelor nous a reçus d'ailleurs avec
olivier le bachelor et voilà ça change
oui c'est avec sandra du beh l'arrivée
de ces visages avec 100 brasse qu'il
faut te dire c'est qu'alexandre à
olivier en fait ils ont pris conscience
qu'ils s'aimaient vraiment c'était plus
un jeu c'est plus la télévision
c'est dans le palais impérial de vienne
pendant la fameuse valse d'un seul coup
ça a été voilà vous êtes toujours un art
ils sont toujours ensemble ici au togo
france et un de melun c'est un vrai nom
c'est un vrai soutien
elle a dit jamais quelqu'un ne m'avait
regardé comme ça nous habite
je suis folle
c'est sans délai
depuis je suis folle de lui et ça dure
toujours
malgré quelques problèmes il faut bien
le dire intestinaux n'ont pas eu des
problèmes de non lieu dès prennent le
vie privée et de flaques il aurait
maintenant pas du tout il ya eu des
problèmes de vie privée quand tu le sais
laurent qu'est ce que je sais dire tu
sais bien qu avec sandra et bordélique
elle arrange pas et que ça énerve
olivier c'est bien un effort et puis
aussi des problèmes de vie
professionnelle c'est à dire qu'olivier
vous a beaucoup reproché avec sandra de
ne pas être mondaine non à colombier
dans une soirée avec lui vous ça vous
amuse pas de serrer la louche des gens
voilà c'est tout mais non mais c'est
juste que lui un peu plus ouvert lé plus
vers les gens et moi un peu moins bon
alors qu'andy donc vous vous êtes
d'opération séduction sur m6 c'est vous
oui alors vous vous êtes taper bertrand
et des chiffres et des lettres
excusez moi vous êtes taper bertreau
callen comme ça dans la télévision
à la télévision il faut vivre autrement
qu'à l'extérieur mais tu es qui pour du
juge était d'abord mis à l'eau voilà
diana donc île de la tentation lors vous
êtes la fameuse diana de diana et
brandon et moi je tapais égaux oui voilà
vous êtes ap hugo parce qu'en fait il
était tellement méchant avec vous
brandon que quand vous êtes arrivé sur
l'île de la tentation j'ai craqué sur un
jean voilà vous vous êtes dit je m'en
tape et un autre avec pour le faire
chier c'est vraiment ça qui est ce que
cela fait vraiment ch y va carrément
ouais j'ai commis beaucoup d'infidélité
avant quelques 400 antennes à wenn man
utd zam non
alors c'est incroyable parce qu'après
vous vous êtes mariés quand même avec
brandon malgré tout après un single
parce que c'est ici qu'on dise ingall de
la télé ce mari a demandé s'il écoute
moi bien il faut un single qui s'appelle
c'est pour la vie et des vins et après
ils vont au mariage et le jour du
mariage alors que tout le monde est là
lui dit non cvs sur la face b y'avait
j'aime pas ta gueule
les deux euros vos personnages là ça
pourrait oui c'est la même
non c'est juste dommage elle est ici
cela dit c'est là même une chanson mais
la différence est non alors
non mais il se rappelle carcassonne il
faut qu'ils me disent que vous êtes à
chier mais arrête de me dire gauche a
choisi je vais mais j'aimerais je veux
te lances dans la gueule on est dans le
même phénomène
donc est-ce que tu suis jusque là jamais
je suis quoi la nécessaire sécurité le
bad buzz olivier c'est la mémoire d'eric
année par mondaine et finalement ça se
passe pas dit que ces mariés ils sont
pas marre ils sont ensemble d'accords
ils sont trouvés dans l'émission est bon
ensuite elle se tape bertrand d'accord
ok donc j'arrive à suivre ses tablettes
et ça c'était sur toi et si c'était
opération séduction perdre ses luxueux
ensuite donc diana elle avec brandon
elle le tronc pour se venger elle le
trompe avec hugo devant le maire elle
dit non et qu'elle est quand elle est
avec moundir
elle va à la télé pour dire toujours à
brandon je suis avec moundir et ça c'est
quelle émission n'est de la tentation
ok super en fait il faut l'expliquer
qu'à chaque fois qu'on fait une télé
réalité on revient pas seul en est avec
ça veut dire quand certains de ce bateau
voilà
cheveux longs mois je ferais je suis
venu à l'origine une merde je t'emmerde
tu m'entends
l'afm et là il ya un problème d kimm île
de la tentation 2 2 fois et là le couple
conformité avec arnaud s'est déchiré
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais c'est pas
vrai un couple ne ressort pas indemne de
ce genre d'expérience ça il faut le dire
il supportait pas de voir des mecs qui
parlent et de vos goûts sexuels non
c'est oui maintenant il s'est fié à des
célibataires qui parlait de moi c'est
pas moi on n'a jamais vu de photos
personnelles qu'on promet une tente où
on n'a jamais eu de preuves concrètes
mais c'est vrai que ce genre d'émission
amène à perdre la tête qu'on devient fou
et je le comprends tout à fait il n'a
pas supporté bon c'est normal c'est le
propre de la télé réalité il faut qu'il
se passe des choses donc on me pousse
les gens limitent à bout ouais voilà
c'était quoi l embrouille mais chacun
sait qu'elles n'ont pas du tout bien au
contraire je tiens à le dire c'était
plutôt pas mal par rapport à d'autre
part fait mais en termes de prix entre
nous pas mal parce que justement alors
maintenant passe à marlène a mâché et
remâché story 2 alors marlène restera
dans l'histoire pour avoir quitté love
story 2 au bout d'eux-mêmes pas une
semaine qua non alors on a dit que c'est
la production qui vous avait jetée parce
qu'il avait découvert qu'en fait vous
étiez une call girl et ils pouvaient pas
parce que ségolène royal a que vous
aimez bien j'étais bien précis tu
particulière ségolène royal a dit que ça
frisait le proxénétisme qu'on pouvait
pas enfermer des call girls band et dans
des lofts quoique à un moment c'était
quand même beaucoup même si on est en
plein libéralisme et les chaînes de
télévision doivent gagner beaucoup
d'argent quand même des gens voient
on a dit que j'étais qu'alger sous le
nom de carla il c'est vrai que le
premier soir dans le loft vous aviez
quand même présenter les hommes en 10
ans et des petits crunch que je déguste
regarde il n'y avait plus de plans
destine alors cette émission les
sanctionner non en fait je disais j'ai
ça que l'on peut dire à mon petit chéri
ou c'était mon expression propre la
vérité de l'histoire avait rétabli ce
cas c'est que quand vous dites vous ce
soir ici je n'ai jamais été qu'alger non
je n'ai jamais été comme gorges était
coiffeuse j'ai gagné ma vie dure aux
mains et mais non j'étais j'étais
enfermé dans ce loft et je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais pas j'avais pas
forcément ma place parce que j'avais ma
maman qui était malade à ce moment là on
n'avait aucun contact avec la famille on
était complètement et moi j'avais la
teste plutôt ailleurs et j'étais pas à
la plage mais j'avais envie de sortir
j'étais pas bien parce qu'une qu'alger
rfr dans une télé réalité elle gagnait
mieux en étant call girl pas s'enfermer
trois mois avec avec n'importe qui et à
voir la tête de marlène franchement sa
douceur sa gentillesse je la connais du
pognon parce que très joli mais je pense
pas qu'elle ait assez de force de
caractère et et
est trop sensible pour faire qu'en
longueur faut vraiment être abondant
vici c'est ce à quoi je ne sais pas ce
que je la connais suffisamment depuis
longtemps et je pense aux savoirs c'est
fini oui et donc je ne pense pas qu'elle
pourrait faire ce genre de l as voulait
partir et c'est vrai que c'est un
élément c'est quand même une nouvelle
fille on voulait la garder dans cette
émission elle voulait partir et bien
comme elle est partie d'elle-même on a
trouvé quelque chose à dire sur l
comment on m'a dit star du x on n'a
d'ailleurs jamais trouver une case et
pour rigoler je m'étais star du x c'est
vrai que quand on va pas dans le sens
que la production demande banon met fin
à jouer j'avais déjà envie en tout cas
fin jusqu'aujourd'hui gens souffrent dit
beaucoup de choses et c'est vrai que ça
fait beaucoup souffrir ma c'est le
revers de la médaille est voulu me
mettre m'exposer bain est maintenant
attendu ce qu'on veut c'est pas grave et
ben voilà mais quelque part tu parles
m'en plaindre parce que j'ai pu en
sortant du love j'ai rencontré filet
c'est beau de la sq il faut dire
évidemment les rencontres et phil barney
ils ont fait un disque un enfant de toi
une reprise en vod du grand succès de
phil barney bien sûr et marlène fait un
nouveau single qui s'appelle ma vie est
un combat il se passe plein de trucs à
pied c'est la moindre des choses pour
une pédiatre is effectivement ma vie est
un combat si votre nouveau single
marlène absolument voilà alors il ya un
dvd
tu vas tout ça voilà bien un dvd cd
brune contre les blondes
alors les brunes sont coachés par
moundir de koh lanta c'est votre jules
mondher maintenant c'est fini
ah oui
[Applaudissements]
j'allais même pas moi j'ai appris que
cette séquence et brandon à moundir
si maintenant vous avez quitté moundir
ça va trop vite pendant cinq ans trois
garçons c'est pas énorme et les blondes
sont coachés par david de love story
plein axe à me regarder par personne
perso voilà alors on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble alors les brunes vous dit
magnéto serge 1-2-3 m'a dit on au cern
pourquoi serge aurier et blanc le sait
plus quel coût
ces deux couleurs qui se battent
quand je ferai mais sinon
défi de télé réalité qui veulent se
mettre sur la gueule bah tant mieux j'ai
la meilleure équipe et si je l aimais
tant pis pour les autres
terrebonne sont près de 150 et l'a
acheté n'importe quel mot sur le ring
seulement voilà si je perds avec honneur
[Musique]
attaquer les combats commencent et qu'on
est l'heure de vérité
beaucoup de choses se jouent dans la
tête on veut quelque chose retirer
ah ah
[Musique]
bien fait ou c
je
oui
pourquoi vous avez fait ça c'est pas
plus simple de faire directement un film
porno hasan aurait la voix annonce qui a
pas d'étude en dvd d'un combat par
combat de boxe s'est pas fait de boules
thierry non mes fins que je tiens à dire
c'est que y'a aucune forme de vulgarité
dans ce dvd c'est classieux
c'est ce canton ce combat on va pas se
tirer les cheveux et moustache que on se
dira je sais pas à thierry je sais pas
si l'excédent savez dvd si tu regarde
pas ce que ça te fait de l'effet oui ça
t'excite oui
abbas était un problème avec toi même
bon alors là tu m'étonnes que ribas que
les a vraiment rien de scabreux je
prends du délire lanthier je parle pas
de la bande-annonce - et dans les
méthodes efficaces cole qui se caressent
qui statuent ce pour être vulgaire est
moins ça t'a fait bander non mais oui il
peut pas pour des raisons médicales sur
un bien car il ya un gros problème parce
que là y'a rien maintenant je veux dire
c'est fait et lui vous qualifiez
gladiateurs êtes intéressés par les
gladiatrice bel égalisatrice in aménas à
l'époque enfin à l'époque des
gladiateurs hommes et il y avait des
gladiatrice qui était d'ailleurs très
spectaculaire et qui faisait les combats
qui ravissait le peuple messier mais
c'est vrai que c'est ça qu'ils essaient
de retrouver la wii mais je suis pas sûr
que ces chiens peu embarrassé ouais je
suis pas sûr que le fait de prendre dix
belles filles de l'est m 8les sur sur
piste
oui
et continue par le mois encore non ça
suffit il faut se battre
c'est une chose qui me fasse totalement
et que c'est bien vous d'apporter un peu
de spectacle et fille qui joue au foot
mais alors moi je dis spectacle j'ai
aucun problème j'ai un vidéo club je
vais louer des films je lis des bouquins
j'ai besoin de voir dix bonnes femmes
avec des combinaisons et d'exercices m
mais alors il se loue des faits mais oui
mais non non non moi je n'ai que ça ne
s'adresse pas simplement aux jeunes et
les attend pour la bouteille d'huile
d'olive c'est derrière
déjà on veut montrer que les blondes
elles comptent pas pour des caméras dans
les rues les brunes qui tapis dans
l'ombre
c'est un problème majeur vient aussi de
quoi bien racisme anti rousse passe car
aucune rousset dans les blondes ua pas
stv ça fait deux erreurs bien
tous les cas c'est un beau cadeau pour
la fête des mères
et je sais qu'on offrira maman zerbo qui
allonge aussi bon c'est vrai que
maintenant vous allez faire les faux
seins contre les vrais seins non
pourquoi pas ouais avec sandra toi non
mais voilà c'est parti là maintenant et
d'avoir un maximum non mais pourquoi pas
ouais pourquoi pas on est là pour
défendre négatrice la demoiselle de là
pour défendre son livre chacun défend
toi tu es là pour défendre le film qui
n'a pas marché d'aller honte à tous ses
côtés on n'a pas été le voir parce que
c'était damien parce que tu as trouvé
les clés de la bagnole scandale étant
donnée la bande-annonce excuse moi mais
au moins c'était drôle qu'est ce que
j'aurais aimé
le gros sel
[Musique]
voilà pour des raisons de place et
jusqu'au blind test on va être obligé de
regarder que de nom on va se superposent
et non superposez tout de suite lors on
a dit quand s'y superposent et après
l'émission
bon on a gardé diana et kim les autres
entreprises à fond
je joue le jeu
ça c'est sûr
on est collé
à têtu dès maintenant
m
chacun attend dominique lapierre et
larry collins
[Musique]
quant au hasard ça va 100 millions de
lecteurs mesdames messieurs ça fait du
monde a quand même un temps lolita paris
brûle-t-il où tu porteras mon oeil au
jérusalem
cette nuit la liberté le cinquième
cavaliers 100 millions de lecteurs 10
millions d'exemplaires bravo
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui c'est le grand retour
de lapierre et collins vingt ans après
comme les comme les mousquetaires avec
new york brûle-t-il qui est un livre
absolument époustouflant mais soit que
ce qui est merveilleux
thierry si on peut le dire c'est comment
nous sommes revenus ensemble après 24
ans de séparation
ouais ça qu'on a été on était les amis
toujours depuis 50 ans on sait qu'on
s'est rencontrés pendant notre service
militaire
et puis un jour on s'est réunis puis
pendant sept ans on a été absolument
concurrents sur les routes du monde un
jour la rime enfermé dans ma chambre
d'hôtel à bagdad
parce que je travaillais pour
paris-match pour m'empêcher d'envoyer
les photos de la révolution irakienne et
lui travaillaient à newsweek il a été le
seul à voir ses photos
je me suis vengé quelques semaines plus
tard en lui donnant un faux horaires de
chemin de fer pour un train qui partait
de djibouti vers addis abeba et j'ai été
le dernier à interviewer le négus et un
jour on s'est mis ensemble et on a écrit
la plus belle histoire franco américaine
la libération de paris
parler d'haïti et ça a été paris
brûle-t-il et on a fait donc ses cinq
livres dont vous parlez est pourquoi
vous êtes séparés alors bien en 1981 moi
j'ai eu un coup de foudre pour l'inde et
particulièrement pour une vieille dame
un peu ridé avec un sari bordée de bleu
qui s'appelle la mère teresa dans un
bidonville de calcutta et là j'ai
découvert des gens tellement
extraordinaire que je me suis dit je
vais faire un livre sur ses héros ses
héros du tiers-monde qui nous donne tout
parce qu'ils ont l'espérance le courage
la capacité de partager avec plus pauvre
que je savais que larry n'aimerais pas
passé deux années dans un bidonville de
calcul hta sévère il avait absolument
raison il a
lui-même un projet de livre et j'ai donc
écrit la cité de la joie
et puis on a fait quatre listes cinq
livres séparément et dans justement dans
le sillage du 11 septembre
on s'est dit parce qu'on se retrouvait
toujours et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'essaye y ait pas d un d'écrire un
nouveau livre ensemble
mais cette fois pas un livre d'histoire
un roman qui serait au coeur de
l'actualité
et si bel laden allaient plus loin que
d'envoyer des avions sur les tours de
new york
s'il mettait une bombe atomique dans la
ville de new york et qu'il donnait ses
cinq jours au président d'alors qui
donne cinq jours au présent états unis
pour faire pression sur israël pour
évacuer les territoires arabes occupés
mais il fallait savoir d'abord si
c'était plausible
nous voulions faire quelque chose
d'absolument réel alors on a fait une
enquête mondiale pour découvrir
est ce que ben laden pourrait avoir une
bombe atomique et larry peux vous
raconter que au pakistan on a fait des
découvertes absolument oui c'est ce que
bernard henri lévy nous a appris avec
son bouquin sur daniel kern c'est à dire
qu'il avait une bombe pakistanaise qui
en fait c'était une bombe islamique cinq
ans
aujourd'hui oui le 30 mars dans
l'arsenal pakistanais et surtout ce qui
est intéressant est inquiétante
ces mômes sont sous la garde d'un petit
corps d'élite de l'armée pakistanais qui
est complètement infiltré à l'aise
islamistes extrémistes
alors je reprends donc trois ans après
le 11 septembre les terroristes cache
une bombe au coeur de new york
et si le président aux états unis
n'oblige pas les israéliens à quitter
les colonies dans les territoires arabes
occupés manhattan sera rayé de la carte
c'est le pitch de votre histoire
les terroristes donne cinq jours aux
américains pour le faire sinon new york
sera transformé en un nouvel hiroshima
il est trop tard pour évacuer la ville
le compte à rebours commence alors
évidemment tout le monde se demande
quelle va être la réaction d'ariel
sharon et ariel sharon dit je peux pas
accepter ce chantage sinon c'est la fin
en israël il ya même un moment où les
américains s'apprêtent à attaquer à
intervenir dans la bande de gaza a été
passionnant thierry dans cette enquête
c'est de découvrir que tout était vrai
d'abord ces bombes dont parle la
richesse qu'elle pourrait une d'elles
pourrait sortir du pakistan oui et aller
vers new york
oui alors on est allé au fond du désert
du rajasthan la frontière entre l'inde
et le pakistan la nuit pour découvrir
les caravanes de chameaux qui transporte
la drôme d'un pays à l'autre et sur un
de ses chameaux peut transiter sept bons
services conviennent mauvais tomic
environ 120 kg oui c'est bombe
pakistanaise
et alors là la caravane passe la
frontière arrive dans ce désert
incroyable du rajasthan jusque cette
ville de gsm mire de la demande dans une
camionnette et va à bombay et là des
gens la mettre dans un container et on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui qu'il ay à 5000
containers qui arrivent chaque jour dans
un port comme celui de new york et
seulement 2 % sont contrôlés c'est à
dire même pas une centaine parce que
tout le commerce international
aujourd'hui se fait par ces containers
donc d'envoyer un tel engin dans cette
ville de new york
c'est un jeu d'enfant et ce qui est
vraiment terrible c'est que nous nous
avons dépensé nous à l'américain ne m
est pas moins 87 milliards de dollars
peut faire la guerre contre l'irak et de
l'année dernière on a défoncé 40
millions de dollars seulement à aménager
le sécurité de nos portes
c'est là qu'on fait ce qui est génial
dans votre bouquin c'est que c'est
possible quoi c'est tout est vrai est
vrai tout est véridique disons non mais
vous n'êtes pas peur de donner des
ballons on n'a pas peur d'eux de donner
des idées à ces gens là où c'est même là
a déjà écrit deux fois disons que les
islamistes des vrais ça mais avec des
demandes leclerc nous savions qu'il a
rencontrés deux fois à cabourg le père
de la bombe pakistanaise abdul qadeer
khan
on n'a pas de leçon à donner à ossun
mcgill à descendre les sens à donner à
nous immiscer partie chant sont restées
telles enquêtes comme ça par exemple on
s'est aperçu que les américains avaient
mis au point des petits gadgets pour
détecter les radiations atomiques et ils
les ont placés tout autour de new york à
l'entrée de tous les péages des tunnels
des ponts et tout ça mais sans plus une
champions service mais là ils ont pu
réviser pourquoi ils sont plus en
service parce que pendant les huit
premiers mois où il était en service
ils ont enregistré 70 milles alerte de
gens qui sortaient d'un hôpital après
s'être fait faire une chimiothérapie et
une radiothérapie et flic devenu
absolument fou et finalement on a tout
débrancher c'est dire que c'est
pratiquement impossible de vraiment
vérifier qu'un engin atomique ne
pourrait pas entrer dans une vie c'est
l'apocalypse ans on a donné beaucoup de
boulot à faire
jérusalem et on va nous donner encore un
peu au new york va faire au new york
on veut pas qu'ils soient temps normal
si une bombe atomique explosé à new york
ce après quoi un million morts tout est
calculé alors on a découvert des
fonctionnaires extraordinaire qui
avaient passé leur vie à déterminer que
sur la 71e rue il resterait cette
vétérinaire quatre infirmières et tout
ça tout ça est complètement fausse et ça
met un million deux cent mille morts si
elle était placée au centre et 6
novembre
et si le vent souffle de la mer c'est
toute l'amérique qui s'était enfin c'est
tout le reste des états l'environnement
et ce qui est quand même encore faut il
a pendant les années de guerre froide
on a dépensé des millions des millions
de l'ap construire des abris des abris
contre les armes nucléaires et des ordis
antiatomique réouvrir alors qu'est ce
qui est arrivé à thématique il devient
dizaine d années il éveille un
tremblement de terre au nicaragua très
gentil on intéresse chercher tous les
provisions qui étaient là dedans on les
envoie nicaragua tous les gens qui ont
mangé on tombait malade et on a visité
un de ces abris et là y'a une pancarte
de la sécurité civile américaine qui
datent de la guerre froide on voit
conseils à suivre en cas de risque
d'explosion atomique alors on voit
ouvrez la fenêtre
ensuite on voit des simples col de votre
cravate et puis mettez vous dans la
position du foetus
il ya comme ça dix recommandations et la
dernière c'est merveilleux en question a
good bye
né à baiser d'adieu à votre cul ouais
enfin en même temps c'est terrible quoi
parce que quand on lit votre bouquin
enfin moi j'ai ouï mais j'étais philippe
et c'était parce que c'est possible on
peut sortir une bombe du pakistan on
peut la rentrée dans new york
on peut la mettre centre de new york les
appareils de détection aujourd'hui quels
que soient leur sophistication sont
absolument incapables de 2,2 de voir où
est la bombe
tu vois pas ce que les radiations sont
pas assez fortes il suffit de la mettre
dans une gaine en plomb auquel peu de
radiations rue mais en fait en même
temps thierry ce qui est fantastique
dans une enquête comme celle que larry
et moi nous avons pu faire c'est que
finalement finalement elles sont pas
sept bambins
ce sont des gens tout simple mais elle
souhaite pas passer un roman attendent
et nous y elle saute pas parce qu'un
flic un peu plus malin qu'il a lancé
merveilleux travailler avec ces flics
dormir au chaud en jeu de dire couvrir
je veux dire le livre est extrêmement
convaincant on est on est terrorisée du
début à la fin il ya un truc que vous
dites pas d'ailleurs c'est qu'à un
moment sharon dit ben moi je vais
envoyer des bombes atomiques sur le
pakistan dire que moi je vais détruire
la ville de karachi je vais envoyer des
bombes ce qu'ils peuvent le faire
aujourd'hui les israéliens ils ont
laissé le shérif qu ils peuvent le faire
donc c'est tout à fait des choses qui
sont d'aujourd'hui alors après vous
dites que grâce à un flic un peu plus
malin que les autres
oui si on arrive à s'en sortir et non
pas grâce à un flic plus malin c'est ça
qui est formidable c'est que ce sont ces
gens là qui qui sauvent et résoudre des
situations on a rencontré une femme le
11 septembre ils ont passé avec chose
qu'ils savaient pas si simple à la isla
ils savent on a rencontré une fille
formidable qui s'appelle l' indice une
américaine de 35 ans très haut niveau de
scientifiques
si dans un cas pareil elles étaient
appelés ce serait elle une fois que la
bombe aurait été retrouvée qui sera
chargée de la désamorcer
je la trouvais d'abord dominés mais déjà
la retrouver la bombe ce qu'on peut
retrouver une bombe à new york c'est
comme il va juste une aiguille danse
devant il faut lire la géante brûle-t-il
sellal enquête policière c'est
formidable c'est là le thriller et l'a
donc dans cette histoire il ya deux
crans de grands problèmes à résoudre le
premier comment trouver le bon hein
et ça justement à la fin de la journée
c'est le boulot d'un flic comme un flic
parisienne qui connaissent aviv qui
connaît ses casiers qui connaît les
maquis à vide on a trouvé un prix comme
ça new yorker lapasset des jeux avec le
wii peut visiter tout son territoire
mais après les choses le plus dangereuse
et la plus difficile comme 2010 est
amorcé limbaugh et ça on a mis deux
tâches entre les mains d'une femme de 35
ans que gérants us est passé tout
l'après-midi vacallo washington c'est
une nouvellle faisait 6 et elle fait
partie comme inventaire organisation qui
est chargé avec la responsabilité de
retrouver les bandes et les désamorcer
et si elle se trouve devant cette bande
c'était avec la connaissance que si un
fait une erreur
elle peut le faire exploser et plus et
non seulement elle même réel millions d
êtres laquelle tu as vu lolita comment
ils vendent leurs bouquins j'essaie
d'enregistrer d'en prendre de la graine
carcassonne je peux te dire qu'il serait
fier de toi si il est parti si tu vas
nous manquer comme il est enregistré
non mais tu le savais noah a passé de
moison de bonheur
500 kilos de documents boulot c'est
difficile a parfois on est tout seul au
bout du monde téléphoner et puis on se
disait voilà j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
qui est formidable tu devrais peut-être
aller voir cette autre personne qui nous
a indiqué c'est d'abord une
documentation monstrueuse on aurait pu
écrire dix livres avec tout ce qu'on a
rapporté on nous arrivons à madrid là où
le livre vient de sortir en espagne
c'était très très bouleversant d'être
avec nous ces gens encore traumatisés
par cet attentat
et quand nous avons vu une houle et les
dessins du système des systèmes
d'explosion qui ont eu lieu à madrid
parce que une bombe sur les dix n'a pas
explosé parce que l'artificier avec son
téléphone cellulaire s'est trompé il ya
sur le téléphone pm l'après-midi et m
le matin toutes les bombes ont explosé à
7h46 du matin lui s'est trompé il a mis
m elle devait sauter à 7h46 le soir donc
on a pu retrouver cette bombe et c'était
exactement le système de mise à feu que
nous avons imaginé dans new york dit il
quand quand ce cher ben j'espère que
l'avenir vous donnera pas trop raison
pas aussi est-ce que le bouquin est
sorti aux états unis n'ont pas encore
encore il va sortir vers un boom nada
mais il va pas sortir depuis ce titre de
new york div 1-1 il va sortir sous le
titre et donc à les sauver new york
c'est une phrase du commissaire
principal de new york à tous ces flics
pour le dis maintenant c'est à vous de
sauver new york
toute la techno j'avais ça va les
américains savaient les affoler
compétitive a pris les devants à bruce
willis 1 et si ça pouvait alerter nos
chefs politiques nos responsables de la
sécurité leur dire qu'ils nous mentent
qui nous protège pas qu'il faut pas ce
qu'il faut pour empêcher ces actions
terroristes
ce serait déjà un grand pas en avant
grâce à ce livre new york brûle-t-il
délits dont je voulais savoir ça peut
arriver évidemment à paris un nul à rome
dans n'importe quelle ville bien sûr et
à londres mais gardez ce qui est arrivé
hier à lons qu'ont ils ont arrêté huit
terroristes avec des liens avec les
islamistes et une demi-tonne de ma
terreal qui pouvait sauver trois jours
des renseignements venant d'ukraine
apprennent au monde que des ogives
nucléaires de l'arsenal la nucléaire
ukrainiens ont disparu ou sont elles
dans les mains de qui sont elles mêmes
fantastique personne c'est oui c'est
comme quand votre bouquin musharraf
reconnaît qu'à une bombe qui a disparu
mais je suis dit à une bombe qui a
disparu dit oui à une banque d'espagne
ils en ont cinq ans donc et même qu'elle
disparaît voilà mais thierry l'autre
jour le président bush a fait un grand
discours devant une grand parterre des
mille ans américaines pour leur dire le
plus grand danger aujourd'hui c'est le
terrorisme nucléaire
à l'intérieur d'une ville j'avais
l'impression qu'ils lisaient une page de
new york brûle-t-il
je voulais après son discours l'appeler
au téléphone et lui dire au nom de l'art
in ou est-ce que vous accepteriez
d'écrire une préface pour nous clary
clairement on n'est pas protégé c'est
qu'il ya aucun moyen pour aucun jeu
l'espionnage assez yal laissait dépasser
le meilleur moyenne mais il n'ya pas
insécurité totale le plus important pas
vers cet état de sécurité ces deux
tâches et de désamorcer les choses qui
poussent les terroristes vers le terreur
dominique attaqué au cutter il a compris
que la pauvreté est un des moteurs
derrière cette de l'année larry est ce
que réellement on peut considérer
aujourd'hui que si les problèmes en
palestine était réglé et ailleurs est ce
que les thérèse mondial à être nommé
rennes pour une certaine partie des
filières sainte contre l'occident ce
serait une une partie dans tous les cas
c'est époustouflant bravo aux arrêts aux
noms ont frappé récemment merci merci
beaucoup
dominique meyer
collins
multi c'est publié chez robert laffont
bien sûr
il
[Musique]
voici carmen electra
ça
[Musique]
et maintenant je me suis d'abord dit non
mais heureusement l'équipe dominique et
larissa il ya le vg c'est énorme bien
alors carmen electra bon soit vous êtes
ici pour la promotion du film starsky et
hutch adaptation au cinéma de la fameuse
série télé avec ben stiller owen wilson
alors vous avez une dure journée
aujourd'hui c'était terrible pour vous
parce que j'ai vu ce matin sur m6 à 8
heures du matin
ensuite j'ai dû faire plein d'interviews
pour la presse ensuite en mai les fonds
chez laurent ruquier
après vous êtes ici c'est difficile non
quand même des journées promotionnelles
comme ça non effectivement c'était une
bonne journée on peut aller faire des
courses aller chez chanel et dior
j'ai été voir
là je cours de louvres alors ces
journées oui ça vous plaît de faire sa
ba dans une ville aussi superbe que par
ivry j'adore évidemment c'est la
première fois que fils ici alors j'ai
vraiment voulu en faire le maximum
pendant cette journée vous vous êtes en
france pour combien de temps je m'en
vais demain et après vous faites comme
ça en fait l'angleterre l'allemagne
l'espagne l'italie la tchécoslovaquie
l'ukraine tout ça non non j'étais au
royaume uni pour la promo de starsky et
hutch à venir ici et mais après je dois
repartir aux etats-unis et non vient
alors à tout reprendre de zéro laurent
si tu veux bien un
alors vous êtes né dans l'ohio votre
vrai nom c'est à rallye patrick parce
que je hais ce que vos parents à cause
de tara et de vivienne lis vos parents
étaient influencés par autant en emporte
le vent non oui ça peut être été autant
en emporte le vent c'est possible alors
j'ai commencé la danse à 5 ans vous
rêviez de broc doué et très tôt très tôt
carmen vous apprenez à vous exprimer
avec votre corps ne vous n'avez pas peur
de vous déshabiller vous jouez beaucoup
et votre sexualité très jeune ça c'est
drôle puisque en fait j'étais vraiment
très très timide très prudent très
timide à l'école c'était moi qui me
cachais derrière tout le monde au fond
de la salle
je voulais va mettre devant à l'avant
dans la casse
je me cachais pour nous changer l'heure
c'est vrai que j'ai un peu changé de ce
point de chute à un petit peu oui
pas tellement alors à 9 ans vous entrez
l'école de création artistique et vous
vous comprenez assez rapidement que le
sexe donne un super pouvoir que vous
avez envie de devenir un sex symbol dans
la vie non respectivement j'avais envie
d'être un sex symbol
j'entrais dans la chambre de mes parents
en cachette je regardais un petit peu
leur magazine
je regardais marilyn monroe j'admirais
beaucoup toutes ces beautés d'hollywood
et c'est vrai que c'était un petit peu
mon rêve d'être ce genre de femme un
jour alors l'âge de 15 ans vous devenez
mannequins ils vont rencontrer prins
prinsloo rebaptise carmen electra carmen
à cause de bizet à lectra à cause de la
déesse grecque
et là vous rejoignez sa bande vous
enregistrez même une chanson avec lui
et
[Musique]
s'appelle gogo dancer mais cette chanson
ne connaît pas un succès extraordinaire
et là c'est la galère là c'est la galère
vous êtes obligé de partir à los angeles
ça marche pas elle s'en va là bas
et miracle vous fait refaire les seins
ça a été vraiment pour vous c'est vrai
que c'était un petit peu difficile à ce
moment ça a été terrible vous fait
refaire les seins et là d'un seul coup
non mais c'est vrai et c est lui l
aimais beaucoup ceux d'avant j'étais
petit mais joli quand même à l'essai
mais beaucoup se demandent mais c'est
vrai qu'il l'est les nouveaux ont fait
sa fortune faut dire les choses c'est
vrai car elle est effectivement moi
c'est on m'a mis mes implants ans
injuste après que vous ayez fait
agrandir votre pénis c'est un peu comme
un moment c'est bien
c'est bien réussi quand même non mais
maintenant vous êtes une grande star
voilà
et donc grâce à ses nouveaux seins
carmen electra est engagée pour alerte à
malibu et lee mais oui enfin c'est celle
de suivre
[Applaudissements]
il ya une chose extraordinaire carmen
c'est quand vous allez passer le test
devant david hasselhoff pour pour alerte
à malibu baywatch vous ne savait pas
nager en fait et elle savait courir
orale en justice est très justement vous
saviez pas nager comment vous avez fait
ce jour là
jeudi j'étais pas très bonne nageuse de
toute évidence c'est pour être très
honnête je ne suis pas la meilleure mais
enfin bon je m'en sors plus ou moins
dans une piscine et l'audition s'est
fait dans une piscine j'ai réussi à
décrocher le rôle
mais alors nager dans l'océan c'est
beaucoup plus difficile très froid ça
vous piquent les et en plus david
hasselhoff devait de venait de se faire
allonger le pénis ie6 alors donc ça
tombait à pic
vous avez vraiment
il faudrait qu'au séisme en chine est
pourtant là bas et froide 1 voilà et
donc chèque
c'est grâce à bo ocz donc carmen electra
devient une véritable icône bimbo ça
devient vraiment une star internationale
qui est bien sûr il ça aide d'avoir des
gros seins pour être maître nageuse oui
bien sûr est ce que c'est c'est
d'affronter en tout cas ça c'est sûr que
ça m'attire notre cible je sais que tu
es très cool et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment tout le monde venait à malibu
pour se noyer
effectivement pas mal joué et c'est vrai
que pamela lantonnais un petit coup de
main les sauver et pourquoi la série a
été arrêtée parce que toutes les filles
de la série avait les seins qui tombent
et c'est pour ça vrai lorsque les
testicules comment c'est un peu le même
phénomène
un met très bien je connais bien car
hésitent à l'époque d' alerte à malibu
que vous rencontrez le fameux dennis
rodman le fameux basketteur
voilà alors carmen electra rencontre le
fameux dennis rodman donc
et alors non rodman et là vous décidez
de vous marier tous les deux est très
très amoureux il a dit le jour du
mariage
je voudrais tourner un film porno avec
elle c'est quand même le plus beau
compliment qu'on puisse faire une jeune
mariée
franchement j'ai rarement entendu
quelque chose de plus romantique mais
vous avez quand même des problèmes
ensemble vous vous disputiez beaucoup
vous disputiez beaucoup souvent les la
police était obligée d'intervenir parce
que vous cassiez tout dans les chambres
un peu comme des rock stars non c'est
pas vrai tout casser dans la maison bon
on n'a pas cassé les assiettes tête de
trois choses ça et là mais pas les 7 7
mais c'est vrai que c'était une période
difficile
et en plus quand on est sous les feux de
la rampe tout le monde vous regarde on
fait on regarde tout ce que vous faites
et tout perd complètement toute
proportion s'est monté en épingle elle
savait où vit des expériences difficiles
on a connu des tragédies ma mère est
décédée du cancer ma soeur et marque une
semaine plus tard
alors je ne savais pas comment faire
face j'avais jamais perdu quelqu'un que
j'aimais autour de moi et j'étais
complètement perdue j'ai énormément
souffert et c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là
j'ai fait le mauvais choix
ça vous est certainement arrivé aussi ça
arrive à tout le monde
bien sûr on ne sait pas toujours comment
réagir
mais en tout cas ce qui est le plus
important c'est que nos expériences à
nous apprennent des choses nous font
avancer et c'est ce que j'ai fait vous
êtes resté combien de temps avec dennis
rodman marié cinq mois c'est bien quand
même
là bas ils tombent britney spears à vous
l'appréciez toujours beaucoup d'aînés si
vous fait rire non c'est quelqu'un que
vous aimez bien non en fait
j'ai dû changer mes numéros déménager et
j'ai complètement perdu du jeune j'ai
changé dit complètement schoettel oui
mais voilà ensuite vous rencontré dave
navarro qui est un ancien de red hot
chili peppers vous vous mariez là aussi
du marié s'est facilement et alors le
cadeau de mariage de carmen electra
c'est du viagra et vous avez beaucoup
apprécié le viagra vous ça vous a fait
un effet extraordinaire
vous avez baiser vous dit on à baiser
comme des fous pendant des heures un
médecin qui est si vous voulez docteur
rock'n'roll et il est venu chez nous
pour nous confier un petit peu enfin
nous donner quelque chose pour qu'on
soit pas trop sous stress avec tous ces
films qui se faisait et il nous a offert
du viagra c'était cadeau de mariage non
pas que quiconque en avait besoin
bien sûr mais on l'a pris ensemble la
nuit de noces ont trouvé ça amusant et
en fait on avait un mal de tête
épouvantail terrible après vous avez
déjà essayé vous le viagra non vous
jamais c'est que les filles peuvent en
prendre me paraît pas besoin tu sais pas
j'ai jamais essayé complètement normal
ben justement c'est parce qu'on est
normal c'est que vous l'avez bien
l'extraordinaire
voilà donc une migraine épouvantable et
ensuite alors ensuite vous faites au
cinéma carmen scary movie est
aujourd'hui donc starsky and hutch
est ce que vous pouvez dire en regardant
la caméra du loup cadiot caméra un usec
magnets au crh vidéo vidéo quand ça va
capitaine je suppose que vous vous
connaissez que vous a peut être sympa à
l'esm autre adulte et va refaire ta
permanence nous il faut qu'on corrige
mes cheveux bouclés naturellement je te
signal non je ne crois pas touche
pourquoi vous le touchez
le détective david starr ce qui suivait
le règlement à la lettre le détective
kate hudson lui ne l'avait jamais lu des
enfers j'étais là à 8h kw à 8 heures je
savais pas que ça ouvrait aussi des
listes mais il se retrouve face à une
mission des plus difficiles
vous étiez fait pour vous rencontrer
tous les deux gouffres équipe tu viens
le 14 avril de flics légendaire
s'associent et quel bouffon vous amène
contre le plus méchant de tous les
méchants ajouté cheikh rendre l'avion ça
coûte très cher c'est pas donné
ce yacht les appareils dans guerre des
gosses tout ça c'est pas donné et elle
tu crois que c'est gratuit j'adore ta
lincoln le modèle 76 sortira l'année
prochaine mais je connais des types qui
connaissent des types qui volent des tic
j'aime ton style j'aime ta technique
oui
dis moi la culture ont tous choisi la
présence plus j'ai un faible pour les
blondes tant mieux moi j'ai pas de
préférence
[Musique]
on a des questions à poser vous aime
bien les gars enfin surtout toi montre
moi ton nombril
non
cette herbe c'est de la grosse type
d'alabama si je ne m'abuse tu étais
connaît en golf c'est surtout en herbe
que je me connais
on côtoie
car ce clip audio
c'est un méchant et voilà ce que font
les méchants
ma chérie je t'aime héros ça va mon
grand ça va aller
c'est
dans l'eure
j'te d'olmes et
[Musique]
voilà il ya aussi paul michael glaser et
david soul qui te sont les interprètes
originaux qui sont guest star dans le
film mais c'est très amusant parce que
justement quand on nous a parlé de ce
projet du dvd on nous a dit oui il
existe aux états unis du moins pas pas
tout à fait exactement un concept de dvd
réalité on nous a dit oui carmen electra
combattu a fait la lutte avec pamela
anderson
je voulais savoir si c'était vrai si
vous aviez aussi participer à ce genre
de projet étant donné que nous
aujourd'hui nous présentons un dvd de
lutte
en france on vous a dit ça pour vous le
petit merci les données
et maintenant
voici thierry paillard
[Musique]
thierry paillard bonsoir vous connaissez
tous le monde moi non
a meaux soir lolita oui voilà diana et
lee hee lee laurent bonsoir et le dit
orange
voilà exactement thierry paillard vous
avez 37 ans et après cinq ans de
séminaire dont trois à l'université
pontificale grégorienne
vous êtes devenu moine chartreux oui
pendant six ans oui c'est cette aventure
que vous raconter dans un livre qui
s'appelle le jour où j'ai sauté dans
l'infini qui est édité aux presses de la
renaissance
ça te fait rire qu'il soit devenu moins
avantageux c'est bien et le mal à ça
c'est bien si vous êtes d'accord de
cochon alors page 13 pages 13 de votre
livre vous dites un petit peu comment
vous êtes arrivé là vous dites tout a
commencé par une fin
ma vie a basculé l'année même de ma
naissance un acte de mort a succédé un
acte de vie et c'est vrai que votre mère
s'est donné la mort
six mois après la naissance de vous et
de votre frère jumeau enfin je mourrai
premier drame liminaire ensuite vous
perdez votre très belle maison familiale
qui est située dans le jura au board au
bord de l'un il ya un barrage edf et
cette maison est englouti voyez le mur
se construire bien sûr vous ne vous ne
la voyez plus deuxième perte importante
dans votre vie
ensuite suicide de votre grand mère
maternelle suite à la faillite de
papeterie dont elle était la vérité dont
il s'occupait elle saute par la fenêtre
voilà donc faut dire que vous avez une
vie qui a commencé c'est assez durement
thierry paillard 1 voit la perte du père
du paradis maternelle transformer en
quête du paradis perdu c'est un petit
peu comme ça que vous résumer votre
votre livre et vous avez raison voilà
alors en 1994 vous avez l'âge de votre
mère à sa mort et vous rejoignez la
chartreuse
oui donc - depuis être petite enfance je
désirais devenir moine je désirais me
donner à dieu complètement j'avais une
quête d'absolu
je fais rien les mots choses à moitié
donc je suis allé vers l'ordre qui est
le plus austère les challenges les
chartreux ce sont des ermites qui vivent
en communauté comme illégales et partait
dans cette chartreuse vous laisser coi
derrière vous un boulot quand même non
donc j'étais derrière busch travaillé
pendant deux ans et demi et à ce moment
là je me suis dit
je me suis dit non il faut que j'y aille
j'ai toujours hésité à faire le pas il
faut que j'y aille
c'était une force en moi qui le disait
si je n'y vais pas si je n'essaye pas si
je fais parce que ma conscience me
demande je le resterai toute ma vie en
voulaient c'est un boulot vous laissez
des amis évidemment et vous laisser une
fille alix avec qu'ils étaient déjà
comme des way des relations 10 ans
amoureuse pour pour le moins oui
amoureuse de mon côté ouais alors voilà
alors dans cette chartreuse votre
famille ne pourra vous voir que deux
jours par an et la première visite
n'aura lieu que 18 mois après votre
votre entrée dans la chartreuse et là
vous découvrez effectivement la vie
c'est à dire la cellule vous habitez
dans une cellule qui en fait c'est à
dire mitage dans une petite maison
la pièce avec un jardin attenant 100 m²
à peu près donc je veux dire que pendant
six ans j'ai vécu avec comme blancpain
une ampoule au plafonnier quoi pas tout
ça voilà quatre murs blancs un lit sur
une paillasse une vie très simple
discipline plus très dure pas de
week-end pas de vacances pas de cinéma
bravo les 400 jeunes badiner avec les
amis
enfin rien non rien et vous vous
retrouvez seul avec vous même avec dieu
peut-être mais en tous les cas seul
j'irais déjà me trouvais avec dieu enfin
j'avais pour moi il a toujours été un
ami il a toujours été mon compagnon il a
toujours été
vous avez combien de fois à l'église par
jour dit combien de prières par jour
comment ça se passe on va à l'église
pour la messe le matin un office qui
l'office des vêpres l'après-midi et
l'office de nuit kim mastine plus l'aude
qui dure entre 2 heures et nuit un jour
ordinaire à 3h30
jour de fête en pleine nuit oui en
pleine nuit et puis noël noël par
exemple la fête de noël c'est 80 4h30
puisqu'il ya ma tin plus la messe de la
nuit plus + l'aude verster après on doit
perdre tout sens de la réalité non avec
un traitement pareil non ah non
normalement c'est fait pour être au
coeur de la réalité ouais parce que la
vie est faite de caunes artifices enfin
en tout cas à l'extérieur on se fuient
facilement tandis que là on peut pas se
fuir alors là voilà vous retrouver seul
face à vous même et vous découvrez que
finalement même là vos problèmes sont
toujours là oui mais c'est là qu'ils se
sont révélés quoi je les avais jusque là
mais je ne le savais pas 1 et
alors les problèmes dans les premiers
noms laquelle ses intérêts élevés mais
n'arrivait pas à vous lever
non malgré malgré la cloche le matin mon
arrivée au club xavi - ouais tu vas
aller passer quelques temps chambre
décalé canal faire du bien tu vas te
mettre en face vous n'arrivez pas à vous
lever
il ya le nic offer j ouais moi je sais
ongles
bravo exactement l'onychophagie on mange
saison absolument
et pire que tout la masturbation ouais
vous n'arrivez pas malgré cette vitre et
monacal c'est le cas de le dire vous
n'arrivez pas à perdre cette mauvaise
habitude ce même c'était pire que tout
même terreau pire que tout dire que vous
mais surveillé plus que dans la vie
civile je dirai un mot je sais que c'est
l activité
parce que derrière en fait d'ailleurs ce
qui avait c'est une révolte qui c'est
qui s'est manifestée contre dieu c'est à
dire comme je le ressentais comme
absents et comme je suis entré en
souffrance
je suis entré en procès contre lui
notamment pour
pour une assistance en personne en
danger concernant ma mère et ma grand
mère puisqu'il avait rien fait pour
empêcher de mourir voilà là vous êtes
très tourmentée donc à la fois
évidemment le suicide de votre mère qui
nous obsède vous avez pas encore la
vérité là dessus vous l'aurez après et
puis vous avez des tourments donc la
masturbation on l'a dit mais aussi vous
bande et quand vous priez par exemple
c'est à dire que c'est pas un tourment
c'est c'est la même chose que l'érection
du matin quand on est bien ouais ouais
si c'est ça c'est bien ouais c'est la
gaule quoi ouais la gaule du matin mais
exactement mais le problème c'est que on
pense quand on est là dedans que fin de
la prière que normalement ça ça doit pas
se passer ces textes c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement commun pour ceux qui
veulent rentrer vraiment dans la prière
elle a pris un vocal et c'est tout mais
ceux qui veulent avoir une relation
plus que d'amitié mais vraiment en
quelque sorte amoureuse avec dieu c'est
quelque chose qui peut arriver qui peut
arriver et donc qui m'est arrivé j'ai eu
et j'ai eu donc le prieur qui m'a dit
oui
ne t'inquiètes ne t'inquiète pas pour ça
c'est très commun saint jean de la croix
on parle la croix saint marc là vous
commencez à flipper vous comprenez que
tout ça ne vous ramènera pas votre mère
vous imaginez de vous laisser aller en
public comme ça devant les autres moines
à l'hystérie à l'épilepsie
vous êtes en pleine régression vous
dormez en position foetale déféqué sur
le plancher s'est quand même quand on
est tout seul comme ça dans une séance
où jeter vos excréments au feu enfin ça
ça se passe très mal vous haïssez dieu
juillet votre crucifix oui et c'est
comme ça d'ailleurs que par exemple j'ai
vu la passion la passion du christ je
veux dire que j'ai j'ai pleuré
à un moment donné de duran duran la
projection du film parce que derrière le
crucifix je voulais atteindre la
personne du christ que je ne suis que je
ne supportais plus et donc j'ai
participé en quelque sorte
moi mon enfin mon niveau au lynchage de
7000 ans innocent vous en pensez quoi du
film j'ai aimé ouais il ya beaucoup de
violence
mais ce que j'ai trouvé très très beau
c'est la grande liberté de cet homme
enfin donc du christ fait que moi que je
considère aussi comme un le fils de dieu
je sais que je suis chrétien mais de la
grande la grande liberté en fait tout le
monde veut l'abaisser à moins que rien
et
et il reste le digne et humain il
pardonne
jusqu'au bout je crois moi dans ma
révolte je n'ai pas été capable de dire
père pardonne ouais je n'ai pas été
capable de dire père lors d'un deuil ne
savent pas ce qu'ils font est ce que tu
vomis cet hiver et avait la tête qui
tournait à 360 degrés voilà c'est
important hélas hélas un jour donc
thierry paillard vous apprenez la vérité
lors d'une visite de votre famille vous
apprenez que votre mère s'est suicidé
parce qu'elle était dépressive et vous
apprenez qu'elle était dépressive parce
qu'elle avait été violée oui avant de
rencontrer votre père est là la boucle
est bouclée
vous vous prenez que c'est pour ça que
j'en ai parlé d'ailleurs parce que c'est
quelque chose qui m'a permis d'aller que
déculpabiliser en fait le mécanisme
était le suivant enfin je le sais je le
sais maintenant c'était de me dire dieu
n'a pas été capable de la sauver ouais
moi je vais moi je vais la sauver je
vous aime je vais me donner à dieu et
lui demander de voilà moi je la sof je
me je me donne pour elle donc j'avais un
lien avec quelques étés c'était un
lièvre mortifère et je me suis libéré de
ce lien vous libérer donc vous reprenez
contact avec alix et la fille avec qui
vous flirtez avant avant la chartreuse
vous subissez une psychothérapie et puis
les moines vous vire le grand football
quand même c'est que tous ces moines ils
ont en marre de vous et un jour il vote
avec des haricots
oui et il le gobelet vous presbytère
vous mettrez cotnoir aujourd'hui vous
êtes marié père d'un enfant un enfant ça
va ouais très bien vous regrettez cette
expérience non tout le monde
non moi je pense que si je m'étais marié
entre le séminaire et la chartreuse
j'aurais pas fait ce travail là j'aurais
peut-être mon problème toute ma vie
jusque là qui traînent leurs problèmes
jusqu'à la tombe jean était quelqu'un
buvable invivable avec mon épouse et mes
enfants
non je suis très content et lee c'est un
ordre ceni cela
j'ai envie de dire belle et tragique la
tragédie de l'enfance qui qui déclenche
tout ce processus d'autodestruction et
quand on arrive au processus de la fin
de ce processus ou d'un coup vient la
renaissance
l'insecte c'est l'histoire d'une
renaissance mais il faut être au fond de
la bim pour que pour qu'il y ait un
salut possible fin je sais c'est ça que
tu as et l'étonnant faut être il faut
atteindre le fond et pourquoi juste une
pourquoi le désir de cet enfermement
dans votre cellule seul parce qu'à ça
aussi vous auriez pu choisir d'être un
char mais moi je voulais pas être moi je
voulais pas être je voulais pas être
seul jouet être seul avec dieu c'est
différent maintenant odieux mais
pourquoi est ce que le trouvez comment
pourquoi dieu n'est pas n'est pas venu à
ce moment là selon je crois que son
silence et une réponse c'est à dire que
j'attendais un dieu qui était maternelle
ou maternant j'attendais que tout le
monde tombe et il va au bout de ton
chemin en élite
il m'a dit tu es libre voilà j'attendais
la volonté de dieu pour agir il m'a dit
ah j ai je serai avec toi
[Applaudissements]
le jour où j'ai cette europe
c'est éviter aux prêts
maintenant on va faire une interview
voeu de silence
tu veux
sinon des mois selon la presse sur la
une
voici d'ailleurs le jour où j'ai sauté
dans l'infini
publié aux presses de la renaissance
merci d'avoir été avec nous le thierry
paillard
et maintenant voici malek chebel
à 22 ans
[Musique]
avec les belges chinois qui vous bénisse
et je connais le travail de monsieur est
donc né en 1953 à skikda en algérie
marié trois enfants universitaires
quatre fois docteur quand même hein vous
n'exercez à la sorbonne à berkeley et
stanford l ue si elle est aussi l'été
céiste journaliste spécialiste du monde
arabe et de l'islam
plus spécialement du sexe dans l'islam à
travers une vingtaine d'ouvragés et vous
publié trois livres vous publiez les
grandes religions chez assouline publié
manifeste pour un islam des lumières
chez hachette littératures et le
dictionnaire amoureux de l'islam chez
plon voilà donc on va commencer avec le
dictionnaire amoureux de l'islam est
votre idée finalement dans ce bouquin
c'est de retrouver d'islam ouvert et
tolérant du temps d'averroès cette
civilisation finalement que les croisés
quand ils y sont allés à l'époque on
trouvait beaucoup plus raffinée que la
leur raffiné et sensuelle envahirait
parce que vraiment en orient par le
passé comme aujourd'hui il y a tout un
art si vous voulez de du vivre ensemble
de la confraternité de la sensualité de
l'amour de la tendresse c'est que c'est
quand même des gens qui on va dire
imaginez ou créer quelque part les
aphrodisiaques donc
[Musique]
le préservatif préservatif par les
arabes il serait né en effet dit on soit
en egypte autant de la civilisation
pharaonique ou plus tard mais en tout
cas il est déjà cité au xième siècle par
des théologiens et des exoterres
préservatif en v6 de moutons par exemple
absolument pas essayer la vessie de
moutons long j'ai installé en côte de
porc mais voilà non c'est vrai qu'a eu
cette civilisation très très amoureuse
comme vous dites et aujourd'hui vous
voulez faire bouger les choses et vous
citer la phrase de rilke et qui dit
faire bouger la mer gelée en nous c'est
à dire arriver finalement retrouvé au
delà des des attitudes un petit peu
crispé qu'ont les musulmans les arabes
aujourd'hui retrouver cette grande
époque cet âge d'or voilà le lis la bri
paix à l'extérieur je prétend qu'à
l'intérieur en dessous si vous voulez il
ya tout un art de bien vivre un art de
la jouissance et c'est en cela que
lorient peut être un apport
véritablement aujourd'hui pour
l'occident ouais c'est dans ce domaine
là il peut être tout à fait un
enrichissement de l'occident alors on va
prendre on va prendre les mots du
dictionnaire de l'islam on va apprendre
quelques-uns évidemment pas tout prendre
la circoncision vous raconter la vôtre
d'ailleurs est ce que c'est quelque
chose circoncision la différence qui
dans l'islam est quelque chose qui peut
être abandonnés vous pensez que ça sera
de tout est difficile pour l'instant
difficiles
ouais je le crains difficile pour
l'instant parce que les musulmans
prétendent ou croient que la
circoncision fait partie de l'islam mais
je vous annonce qu'elle ne fait pas
partie de l'islam
oui c'est quelque chose qui remontent à
bien avant donc bien avant autant
d'abraham et déjà même abraham quand il
y avait lui dit de circoncire son fils
lui abrams avait circoncire donc je
prétends qu'il qui la tenait déjà de ses
ancêtres halluin donc la circoncision
est plus ancienne et même aujourd'hui
séoul est sociologiquement
géographiquement parlant
sociologiquement parlant deux tiers des
musulmans qui sont asiatiques ne sont
pas circoncis c'est vrai
et quand ils vont à la mecque et son
pendant qu'ils sont pas circoncis alors
liées à l'excision aussi alors là on
alors l'excision ne fait pas partie de
l'islam un catégoriquement
1 là je vous donne un élément
catégorique sexy vous
comparer les deux cartes la carte
quelque 6 et la carte de l'islam ça se
ça se superposent pas ces 10 juin
aujourd'hui on sait que la série
l'excision gagnent un peu sur le
territoire de l'islam est l'islam la
refuse complètement
quelle est la différence entre
l'excision la clitoridectomie
clitoridectomie deck thomis et dès qu'on
coupe le clitoris l'excision c'est un
terme plus large clitoridectomie on
touche au clitoris lui-même et
l'infibulation aux coûts en cours
exactement coup les grandes les avoirs
du vagin c'est une pratique est courante
dans l'islam pas du tout l'islam la
condamne comme la clitoridectomie comme
l'excision il condamne tout ce qui
touche à la vulve féminine pour lier un
truc encore pire que j'ai appris dans le
bouquin c'est l'excision pharaonique
alors ça consiste en quoi
là c'est une révélation total on coupe
tout c'est un clip que le terreau est
scellé et les grandes lèvres du vagin
mais on dit pharaonique parce que c'est
une pratique qui prétend que son
effarant qui ont qui ont pratiqué ça en
effet donc ce serait antérieure à
l'islam en fait largement antérieure
envisagé l'islam n'a rien à voir avec
tout ça bien en le moharrem vous vous
parlez du mois rêve vous dit le harem
est moribond ça veut dire qu'il ya de
moins en moins de harem dans les pays du
moyen-orient
beaucoup de rng en quantité si vous
voulez les harems été réservé aux riches
aux grands nabab
si vous voulez au grand calife il faut
avoir les moyens pour entretenir ces
talus cher que notre king iii mettra
aussi à sucer ceci c'est très
sophistiquée à tout est codifié et en
plus c'est en train de régresser
je sais pas si c'est une bonne chose ou
une mauvaise moi je
je ne donne pas d'apprécier dans votre
oeil on lit quand même que c'est pas un
truc qui vous déplaît particulière non
partisan je suis partisan pour tout ce
qui fait plaisir
tout simplement ceux qui connaissent le
sujet de l'homosexualité que c'est un
véritable interdit ça dans l'islam dont
l'un dans l'autre vous dites qu à une
homophobie radical est intrinsèque dans
l'islam
oui c'est très très étrange là aussi
parce que d'une certaine manière
évidemment dans une société où il ya
beaucoup d'hommes qui vivent entre eux
et beaucoup de femmes qui vivent entre
elles puisque la mixité n'est pas un
choix social dominant
donc moi ça fait vingt ans déjà que j'ai
commencé à écrire là dessus il ya une
sorte de paradoxe logique là dedans
c'est que si les autres vivent entre si
les femmes vivent entre elles la
première chose qui vous vient à l'esprit
tous c'est qu'il doit se passer des
choses
je ne sais pas lesquels mais doit se
passer des choses et donc
et en effet il se passe des choses ouais
et là ça pose problème parce que en
effet c'est tout à fait interdit par le
coran
ouais la sexualité vous dites que la
chasteté n'existe pas en islam alors
l'islam à régler ce problème dès le
départ c'est que en enlevant la
culpabilité liée au sexe en disant que
la sexualité libre il n'y a pas de
raison d'être chaste ouais et la
chasteté ne ne convient pas vraiment aux
orientaux 1
franchement ils ont tout essayé mais ça
serait déjà le ca lisant ça les arrange
pas franchement ils ont plus c'est pas
l'heure c'est pas l'heure points score
s'il fallait en profiter alors la
sodomie vous dites qu'elle peut être
acceptée dans certains cas si c'est pour
protéger la virginité alors on aide à la
personne
mais julie ce serait le substitut du
viagra non je dis que dans certains cas
de figure il y à une sodomie vicario
c'est un mot compliqué sacs de
remplacement mais ça n'est que très très
ponctuel grand cas de figure car ils ont
déjà des jeunes femmes qui veulent
préserver leur hymen et qui
malheureusement
doivent se commentaires doivent accepter
les propositions on en est aux manettes
de leurs amis avant le mariage et elle
doit préserver à tout prix leur virilité
nous sommes discutable on n'est pas là
dans interdit permis accepté pas
accepter c'est trop schématique c'est
trop schématique
nous sommes à l'été voilà oui oui là
c'est ce qu'on parle de rêve d'imiter
existe aussi bien sûr que c'est très
courant c'est ridicule
finalement deux c'est bien jean préserve
tout non si on veut préserver l'hymen la
sodomie est toléré dans ce cas la crise'
c'est l'hypocrisie
si tu veux la terre moi j'appelle ça
comme ça aussi simple non c'est pas
aussi simple alors il faut il faut pas
confondre chasteté et chasteté si vous
voulez moral et prévenir la réserve
inhumaine comment expliquer justement
dans le fondamentalisme musulman
aujourd'hui alors que c'est vrai que les
mille et une nuits lorient le sexe le
désir la volupté sont partis de la
culture ab
comment expliquer cette comment dire ce
cette rigueur maintenant dans les
musulmans
extremely qui refusent cette sensualité
sera pas avec sa femme quatre siècles de
décadence de l'islam depuis
d'abord il ya eu la reconquête en 1492
donc les arabes perdre l'andalousie
reflux et là je les trouve trop crispés
sur l'identité dont il ya quatre siècles
et nous sommes dans un cumul de quatre
siècles
et puis des gens qui ont perdu le
contact complètement avec la
civilisation de l'islam du pape fait il
écarte le tout ce qui a rapport sexuel
pour essayer de préserver leur religion
c'est ça il ya une sorte de wii ont bâti
la citadelle ce qu'on se protège avec
une citadelle qui le coran le retour aux
sources et on ne veut pas entendre
parler de la réalité d'aujourd'hui du
monde concret cdec avec les complexités
si vous voulez donc il l'a en effet il
ya un refuge est facilité ceci étant
évidemment tout l'islam n'est pas comme
ça donc il faut surtout bien sûr la
danse de mably que moi je fait
l'amalgamé entre le 20 août et musulmans
et surtout les musulmans sont hypocrites
où sont coincés
bien au contraire moi j'essaie de
montrer que l'islam est contre une
religion du bien vivre et de la
jouissance voilà on dit toujours gâté
décision vois pas de de musulmans
modérés de musulmans éclairés malek
chebel vous êtes l'exemple du contraire
voilà alors on passe maintenant à
l'autre bouquin qui s'appelle manifeste
pour un islam des lumières alors là on
va pas prendre les 27 propositions vous
faites une par une mais oui
effectivement on peut être que d'accord
avec vous vous dites affirmer la
supériorité de la raison qu'ils ne
seraient pas d'accord décrété la guerre
sainte
inutile et dépassée on est tous d'accord
abolir les fatwas sur la mort évidemment
abolir les châtiments corporels
l'excision l' esclavage condamner les
auteurs de crimes d'honneur vite que
c'est tribal finalement le crime
d'honneur qui est vieilles jalousies aux
rapports sexuels réévaluer le statut de
la femme rappeler la prééminence de
l'individu sur la communauté dépénaliser
les jeux alors moi j'ai fait les combats
de catch pour les femmes
lu tout ça et je me suis dit finalement
si c'est ce que vous voulez changer dans
l'islam c'est beaucoup de choses à
changer parce que quand on lit les 27
propositions
chez moi ça serait pas plus simple de
devenir chrétien parce qu' énormément
il ya énormément de choses à changer
quand elle va trouver alors 27
propositions 27 chantier en effet
complexe et et cd challenge réellement
ce pour les immenses immense mais c'est
ça le jeu c'est que le jeu vaut la
chandelle si vous voulez c'est que si
vous n'avez pas une religion à changer
quel est l'intérêt là c'est vrai on
abolit on arrête on arrête tout moi je
trouve que c'est intéressant
qu'aujourd'hui il y ait des gens qui
disent ça que la fetwa de mise à mort
c'est avec un écrivain ou un réalisateur
ou un dramaturge eux ne me plaît pas
donc j'ai mais contre lui une fetwa de
mise en examen je trouve ça scandaleux
ce que vous dites c'est formidable mais
on se demande le temps qu'il faudra
parce qu'à moi on parle de laïcité par
exemple vite que même au temps de l'âge
d'or
la laïcité était quelque chose qui était
vécue mais qui n'étaient pas admis qu'il
était pas théorisé tout à fait on quand
on construit votre bouquin sur le
manifeste pour un islam des lumières
11e' mais pour en arriver là il faudra
des millénaires quoi c'était pas du tout
je pense que 90 ont donc dans l'islam il
y a tous à y arrêtent des réponses à
toutes mes questions
dans l'islam dans l'islam authentique le
véritable celui auquel je pense lui que
j'aime c'est avec une vraie rien le
bouquin qui s'appelle les grandes
religions qui est très intéressant aussi
qui a été écrit par des par des
chrétiens des juifs des musulmans il ya
un marc alain ouaknine ya dont robert le
gall claude bille levinson et vous malek
chebel serait le grandes religions c'est
publié chez assouline
et là il ya les principales croyances de
de chaque religion pour qu'on puisse les
comparer pour qu'on puisse leur temps
des symboles en partant des symboles de
chacune voilà tout à fait merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je reçois maintenant yann queffélec
yann queffélec bonsoir bonsoir bas alors
yann queffélec figon qu en 1985 avec les
noces barbares adapté au cinéma par
marion hansel ensuite quinze romans le
charme noir disparu dans la nuit la
force d'aimer boris après l'amour et
vous publié aujourd'hui chez fayard moi
et toi en le titre s'est sans doute à un
clin d'oeil aux bouquins de giraldi non
en suisse et en créatures et moi c'est
un recueil de poèmes à l'eau de rose
comme ça sur l'amour alors que vous
c'est plutôt consacré au chaos du couple
lewis et moi je suis partie de l'idée
qu'au départ dans un couple c'est toi
mon toit mon routeur que vraiment toi
c'est là c'est l'idéal c'est
l'émerveillement et au fur à mesure que
les années passent on constate que le
moins reprend du poil de la bête que le
mois a tendance à vouloir à nouveau
protéger ses abattis et se mettent à
considérer l'autre comme une comme un
véritable adversaire donc finalement
qu'est-ce qu'un casque la question de ce
livre c'est que devient l'amour une fois
que le couple ne pense plus qu'un cas
s'engueuler ouais et en même temps quoi
de plus beau qu'une magnifique discute
passionnel qu'une équipe ordinaire
engueulades
il ya un peu d'autobiographie d'ailleurs
dans ce roman trop j'espère parce que
c'est c'est assez alors je fais le pitch
à michel est amoureux de julia mais
incapable de l'aimer
elle elle fait monter évidemment la
pression en se focalisant sans relâche
sur une supposée maîtresse que leur
fille aurait vu un jour dans la
baignoire bon enfant n'avait pas
tellement sûr ne vous dit pas vraiment
oui pas vraiment si c'est arrivé
et alors comment ce jeu mortel
effectivement extrêmement sadique kills
consiste à se faire mal sans cesser de
se faire du bien parce qu'ils font quand
même l'amour entre we will see si bien
entendu mais quand je disais qu'ils
avaient une autobiographie il faut dire
par là qu il m'est arrivé dans des
disputes que j'ai pu avoir au cours de
mon existence avec eux c'est pas avec
des compagnes de constater que la femme
est toujours juste lorsqu'elle sort
gueule avec l'homme qu'elle est
magnifique comme cela une puissance
oratoire extraordinaire que pendant
qu'on se fait engueuler on n'a qu'une
envie c'est de prendre des notes et
ensuite les écrivains ont beaucoup à
apprendre de la femme qui les engrais et
même d'ailleurs que qu'un écrivain qui
ne vit pas qu'il n'a pas la chance de
vivre avec une femme colérique ne peut
pas écrire de bons livres sur la
question
en même temps c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'ils sont c'est terrible ce rapport de
coupage 43 vous écrivez en ménage ils
étaient 2 bernard l'hermite incapable de
s'éloigner longtemps du lieu où ils
reçoivent coup et vexations
il s'est disputé violemment mais se
réconcilier à la vie à la mort et chaque
fois ils s'aimaient un peu plus cette
espèce de comm ca de 2 millions oui
c'est la patience à ce que j'ai vécu
pendant cinq mois c'est horrible avec
des gars comme ça avec monde d'accord
j'adorais j'adorais et alors j'ai
cherché des discutions disputés puis
après on se réconcilier bien c'est dire
que c'est eux c'est vrai que l'amour à
la longue c'est une injonction
contradictoire c'était à la fois on est
porté vers l'autre on les aime de plus
en plus avec les années on est de plus
en plus attachés à lui et en même temps
on ne cesse dans les engueulades de
vouloir le mettre à mort c'est dans la
parole c'est une espèce de j'aime bien
cette phrase à guitry qu'on a déjà cité
ici c'est l'amour c'est ne plus faire
qu'un seul reste à savoir lequel il ya
cette prétendue maîtresse femme aux
cheveux rouges à genoux dans la
baignoire dont qui a été vu par cette
gamine qui s'appelle pas pareil
d'ailleurs là l'un et l'autre à allure
madonna et cette gamine a des problèmes
psychologiques alors quand la mère dit
mais elle a vu la maîtresse dans dans la
baignoire en guinée vote s'il ya des
problèmes la mer galles elle dit ne
prenait pas ma fille pour une illuminée
donc on ne sait jamais vraiment ce qui
s'est passé on constate que lorsqu'un
coupe ne sommes tellement d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont google toute la journée
c'est forcément au détriment d'un enfant
un qui se sent coupable de la mauvaise
du mauvais état comme ça de la relation
entre ses parents et cette gamine mine
de rien elle est en train de se barrer
complètement oui à cette gamine belle se
drogue elle va en maison de redressement
et l'air pendant tout bout car on attend
qu'elle revienne ils attendent qu'elle
revienne pour partir en voyage sur un
voilier à toulon sur la méditerranée et
là il ya une phrase terrible qui sait
par quel aveuglement ce couple se croit
né sous le signe du grand amour cirque
en fait vous avez raison c'est très
juste que vous dites c'est que tous les
couples même ceux qui se disputent la
journée se croit né sous le signe du
grand amour
c'est un registre est exactement ça
que reste-t-il de ce grand honneur à ses
jours et en même temps lorsque j'ai aimé
en écrivant ce livre justement c'est la
transfiguration romanesque comme ce qui
est le mal qu'il m'a permis de faire
c'est d'ailleurs l'envi de faire
entendre aux lecteurs non pas comme ça
une scène de ménage vulgaire celle qu'on
entend à travers les cloisons trop mince
d'une chambre d'hôtel mais vraiment
quelque chose d'universel c'est à dire
que quand on est con et la pression le
lisant que c'est une résonance personnel
qu'on trouve
ouais alors ils font l'amour mais c'est
terrible parce que lui à un moment il
pense que l utilise sa fabrique sont
membres comme un vulgaire vibro sorti du
tiroir de la commode et à un peu après
elle lui demande comment était sa mère
est là c'est terrible
elle répond douce et molle comme ta
vieille que la sainte alliance
effectivement c'est que devient le
désirent à londres 1 continue d'avoir
des rapports sexuels apparemment ça
fonctionne très bien parce qu'on se
connaît très bien
mais cette espèce de troubles infiniment
mystérieux du premier désir
il est en voie de disparition il est
souvent en voie de disparition est là
mais c'est terrible se rappelle
l'entraîneur
ouais c'est d'une crudité c'est d'une
cruauté il prenait absolument totale
mais aussi aussi lui aussi d'une
tendresse et je ne dis pas ça pour pour
compenser la cruauté médecins on voit
bien à la fin lorsque lorsqu'il est en
train justement de fuir devant sa femme
il repense à elles et ils l'aiment comme
il ne l'a jamais aimé au moment où ils
risquent vraiment de la perte pour de
bon vous pensez que tous les tous les
amours sont condamnés à ce destin
non je ne crois pas mais ce qui est non
je ne crois pas il ya forcément des
exceptions mais lorsqu'on écrit un roman
on écrit si finalement pour essayer de
d'embrasser le rhin situation la plus
générique possible je crois que c'est un
de mes amis canins j'ai pris le plus
grand plaisir
c'est publié chez fayard de l'amitié
[Musique]
et maintenant on passe un blind test
[Applaudissements]
aux platines jabel signer et les
médiatrices pour jouer
[Applaudissements]
alors tous des gladiateurs isme toutes
les villes indiennes crise avec édition
a été émis avant gladiateurs tchané
gladiatrice voilà tout l'un et de
l'autre côté le reste du monde
évidemment avec le lui kapil la honda
fit all in motion rim elin et mais rien
n'est fait nous y voilà
tu veux jouer avec nous j'espère bien
attention vous n'êtes pas de la zour
tout va bien ça va vous être concentré
ouais aller elie ça va ça va ça va c'est
de motiver mes équipes voilà vous
connaissez le principe du jeu je veux
l'interprète première chanson signer
ça va donner
voilà donc c'est l'équipe de la honda
fit qui marque un point
[Applaudissements]
la triste mais on a tous fait yann
disait voilà très bien les lillois qui
dans chaque équipe
voilà bien donc le premier point c'est
pour ton équipe laurent bravo bravo
lance bras volant et on continue sydney
numéro de la tension on se concentre
tout est prêt ouais ouais ouais
tous les shows oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
et ouais
selon m
[Musique]
mais battant
voilà l'on défie deuxième point pour
leur mépris ça fait des voltigeurs
zéro
aho
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas facile encore bravo bravo
vraiment c'est pas facile pour moi
bravo d'accord attention sinon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non l'ouvreur salon lundi le premier
triplé
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
non c'est bien si bien sûr ouais ça fait
3 points pour l'équipe de laurent baffie
ouais
bah je viens pas ici pour être oublié
qu'est ce que vous foutez les fils a
déclaré forfait
c'est tricher en écoutant derrière la
ramaz le seul risque autres bêtes signer
[Musique]
on va bravo l'audio noces va pas et
fanny c'est toi qui l'a dit
[Musique]
bravo toi tu es diana ross ouais voilà
bien donc méline ça fait combien
ah ça fait un point pour l'équipe des
riches ont avec le gladiateur et c'est
gladiatrice attention sydney
alors oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
coco 24 mois pour l'équipe de l'as roma
puis les ventriloques c'est pas moi
c'est toi
du site
au premier tour
n'importe quoi comme ça tout va bien
alors en ont quatre jours pour ton
équipe cb d'un mois manqua pas de
concentration concentration
concentrez-vous luffy attention signer
[Musique]
attention les filles
toute la scène
[Musique]
tu sais je sais
il
m
et non
oh
tourné au jeu
vous l'avez entendu soufflé ne vous
n'êtes même pas capable de répéter ils
disent carmen et vous répétez carmen
carmel non tu dit carmen et kavala
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand vous écoutez c'est bien d'écouter
bien donc 5.1 vo l'équipe de l'hormadi
un poireau l'équipe d'el icha respect
mouais
[Musique]
pour l'équipe ii
bien qu'en mais je connais pas mais
cindy soufflage dollars
toi
la cause
[Musique]
voilà ça a été tellement soufflé par
vous que le printemps est là ça c'est
ridicule c'est fait tu vois bien
réveillère b néron tu fais gagner les
autres bah oui bien donc maintenant par
équipe c'est bien évidemment l'équipe de
laurent baffie qui gagnent bravo laurent
et maintenant
et maintenant maintenant on passe au
chacun pour sa gueule
c'est la fin du pain équipe là alors
lavit jeu parce que la vie est injuste
bien sûr l'or alors alors est ce que tu
es prêt sydney usine
la chanteuse
nous
non
oh
sérieux c'est l'hymne serge à trouver
c'est serge qui va gagner ce soir c'est
mauvais mais il ya deux versions
[Musique]
voilà c'est cherche dans le port de bouc
on ne saurait
gore
oui
un merci signer je rappelle le type de
l'album de signer leur âne donc merci
beaucoup sydney
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
avec leurs deux filles
[Musique]
la paix sur lui
m
qualitel monica bellucci les mayas
les joies guide
sa peinture
bien faire parler
maxime le forestier
à partir d'une
et
grasset le 6 avril
alexandra cambridge a
les gladiateurs
or dit il
6 avril
marlène duval mai
une certaine
dominique lapierre et laraque
j'ai encore la promo 5
car ce qui est illégal et les grands
chantiers du 20e
le single
les quatre italiens
le jour j'ai sauté dans le
au xiii 2
malek chebel dictionnaire noé l'islam
chez plon manifestants l'islam des
lumières cherchez plus tes ratures et
les grandes religions chez insuline
vient du bénin - et toi c'est chez
fabien blind elle sydney single de leur
homme s'appelle taxe aillent reporters
sans frontières qui barre le livre noir
c'était du monde en parle rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
divers candidats têtes en l'air chiffres
en l'air
y allant vers la partie de jambes en
l'air
il aurait redémarré
saleh
je n'ai pas de séparer je suis juriste
même en discothèque gens là sont plus
riches sont ceux qui descendent du
sapiens hyacinthe
pour allier
non mr hallyday dans l'année
wind river pour matra montant
sors plus
[Musique]
jeunesse matinée
heureusement que jamais
c'est la mort
mais méfiance à bad ragaz fait
[Musique]
alors
oui
[Musique]
ordres de l'ecc
je me sentirais
dans une nébuleuse j'aime pulvérise seul
sur le toit du monde au sol du firmament
vient
j'invite tous
ça
ça y est ça
bassin francilien
[Musique]
à la place de dames en février